organizations before granting tax-exempt
status
taking us back to the ill-fated lowest
learner years
the federal election commission will now
be partisan
hr1 alters the current bipartisan makeup
of the six-member commission
to a partisan five-member commission and
and
also establishes a speech czar
limiting free speech and creating a
partisan commission
with partisan enforcement priorities and
after the bill attacks americans free
speech
it creates a public fund to directly
contribute
to congressional campaigns hr one
would launder corporate dollars through
the treasury
and use those dollars to publicly fund
congressional campaigns
based on 2020 numbers that creates
access
to more than seven million dollars in
public funds
to bolster my colleagues campaign
coffers
by providing a six to one funding match
to small donations
i know when i speak with my constituents
back home establishing a program that
helps
me acquire more money for my campaign
is not what they think federal
government should be working on
we submitted amendments to not only
strike this program
and prevent all sitting members of
congress
from financially benefiting but also
require any increase in corporate fines
to be used to help with pandemic relief
we believe helping our country
through this pandemic is a better use of
this money
than lining our own campaign coffers
i hope my colleagues will agree and rule
these amendments in order
again we're offering these 25 amendments
because republicans
have been shut out of the process and we
believe this bill would have a negative
impact
on the american people's ability to vote
and to participate in our political
process
hr one includes election administration
mandates
will be impossible for many states to
implement places restrictions
on america's first amendment right
guarantee
freedom of speech it creates a public
financing program
to line the campaign coffers of all
members of congress
and makes pandemic election law changes
permanent as it's currently written
this bill is not for the american people
it's for the benefit of the politicians
i yield back madam chair
thank you for your comments of ranking
member davis
disclosure requirements have been proven
to not discourage political speech by
the way but
rather expand the public's political
knowledge
so with that i will now turn to mr cole
for any questions
that he may have thank you very much
madam chair
um chair lofgren uh uh
you mentioned in your testimony that you
had a hearing that dealt in part with
h.r one
uh did you happen to have a markup on
the legislation as well
no uh as uh mentioned i think in my
opening statement
we did not we followed the rule that the
rules committee
adopted and the house adopted that
allows uh bills that passed
last year to be considered this year
without an additional markup
we thought however that having an
additional hearing
even though not required would be a good
thing and i thought it was a very
successful hearing
last week hr 1 isn't new it's a
substantially similar version of the
bill
passed the house in 2019 as i said after
five different
house committee hearings and the full
committee markup process
as well as the rules committee and
as well as several other component parts
uh
in hr1 uh including the safe act and the
shield act
and the john r lewis voting rights act
that were
separately uh considered by the house so
there has been
substantial scrutiny as i mentioned we
are simply following
uh the rules as adopted by the house
that do not require
an additional markup for bills that are
substantially similar to those
passed by the house in the last congress
now
just just for the record so you know
that was not a rule i supported
uh on uh you referred the bill to 11
other subcommittees do you know if any
of them had a markup on the legislation
i don't believe the ha the house
administration committee has the primary
jurisdiction
over this bill there are some other
committees with pieces of it for example
homeland on the security piece and
judiciary on the voting rights act and
the like
but i believe that all of the committees
followed the
uh the rule that i've just discussed
which allows the bill to proceed without
additional markups
since it passed in the last congress in
a substantially the same form
uh let me turn to you ranking member
davis do you agree with that assessment
do you think there was no need for a
markup in this legislation
uh thank you ranking member cole
absolutely there is a need for a markup
of this legislation
well it seems like groundhog day that
we're going through these failed
policies once again
just like we did last year just like
this bill originally in the last
congress
was written in the dark of night with
the help of
outside groups dark money groups under
the guise of making good election
reforms
that's not how we should put legislation
forth in this country like they did
in january of january of 20
uh 2019
and we we saw every single democratic
colleague of ours
actually co-sponsored that legislation
before it was even released
they didn't even read the bill however
this law offering is right chairperson
lofgren is right they don't have to go
through a markup because they're in the
majority but this
bill is not the exact same failure that
it was last year
they've actually doubled down and put
hundreds of more pages
into this legislation that would
continue
to take away our free speech rights and
also
nationalize the election process as a
matter of fact
just now chairperson lofgren and
and the majority just put forth another
76 page
managers amendment so this is not an
open process
this is a process democrats are going to
continue to push through
800 plus page bills now with the
managing amendment
absolutely actually almost 900 pages all
under the guise
of trying to game the system to allow
democrats
to keep the majority and to really
line their own campaign coffers with the
first ever corporate money
since 1907. mr cole if i may
i think you know mr davis has introduced
quite a number of amendments as he has
every right to do
and we have also suggested an amendment
as we have every right to do and the
rules committee in its wisdom
will choose which uh to advance i would
just like to note that
this bill had a markup last year had a
hearing last year had a robust debate
on the floor compared to when
republicans were in the majority the tax
their own
uh bill h.r one there was not a single
hearing
uh or mark up the entire thing was don't
be behind
closed doors and was not made public
until
days before the committee markup and the
the effort to repeal
uh obamacare um
there was no hearing on on on the matter
no
cbo score so uh i think to
to criticize this when we did have a
robust process
last year is is a bit disingenuous but i
i don't
let me go back to mr davis uh it's my
understanding about 30
of the text of this is new so
none of that 30 has ever been subject to
a markup is that
uh that is correct and that does not
count the manager's amendment
that was just released today and and
look i i
i'm i respect my good friend chairperson
lofgren
we work together on a lot of issues this
is one issue that
we have some fundamental disagreements
on but he knows that
the majority uh actually runs the rules
committee
so let's not faint ignorance that this
isn't going to pass and be added
to the uh added to the the number of
pages
that we have yet to have a say in our
amendments
are amendments that we are forced to do
that we could have done
during the committee markup mr mr
ranking number but unfortunately we
didn't get the chance
uh chair loftred uh i want to turn to
section
five one one one which is this newly
created government matching program for
small donor uh contributions the section
creates a six to one government match
for any small
donor contributions of 200 or less to a
congressional or presidential campaign
meaning that literally every 200 or less
contribution
uh or a 200 dollar contribution could be
matched by 1200
from the federal government uh seems to
me one of
the concerns that i hear a lot is that
there's too much money
in campaigns already and you know why
are you
adding more i mean frankly i don't know
a single
campaign in the country that was
underfunded in the last congressional
cycle
at least not none of the significant
campaigns were
both sides seem to have more than enough
resources so
why the need to tap into federal money
six to one match and add even more
millions and millions of dollars into
the system
well if i can this this is actually um
representative sarbanes bill that was
introduced in prior congresses and
i think he's going to be a witness later
he may want to talk
more of wholesomely about the program
um but the the intent of it
is to advance public interest not
special interest right now big donors
and wealthy special interests
fund most campaigns uh even if not
funding everyone's campaign directly
they're funding big
super pacs dark money groups this pilot
program
would give political power to ordinary
americans and boost their influence in
their voice in elections
uh the idea is to allow individual
americans to
influence their candidates of choice
through small donations
that previously seemed inconsequential
but with this pilot program those small
donations
would become very consequential because
they would be
matched and so this would invent
incentivize candidates
to be listening to main street and not
wall street
there are some similar programs across
the country
and what we've seen is that they help
increase candidate diversity
so that more people can run for office
and represent their communities
for example in connecticut public
financing
help far more diverse candidates when
state office
in arizona the number of native american
and uh hispanic candidates nearly
tripled
after public financing was implemented
candidates need to re
raise at least fifty thousand dollars
from one
thousand small donors at two hundred
dollars
or less and then there's a a strict cap
on the total amount of fifty percent of
the
average amount of the top twenty most
expensive winning candidates from the
prior
election cycle and in 2018 that would
roughly equal 4.5 million dollars per
candidate
now everyone agrees that the
money out of the federal treasury and
that that to me is the big point
and frankly don't uh you know i mean we
have enormously successful
groups uh act blue and wind red
the two sides that do exactly what you
want to do that is try and take small
donors and
move them around the country uh those
seem to have
succeeded really admirably i think
beyond what anybody believed they would
so well you know pacquiao
as a solution looking for a problem
at blue is actually just a conduit and i
believe although i
don't believe i'm an expert on it but i
think the other uh the
win red group that was established by
republican
um uh supporters
mirrors act blue you'll correct me if
i'm incorrect
it's just a conduit and it's it's uh
it is we're fully reported it doesn't
enhance
no i'm not objecting to it i mean they
all
but but they've injected millions uh
of additional dollars on both sides
again i'm not being critical
of the concept either way but this idea
that there's somehow a shortage of small
dollar donors that strikes me as uh
i mean these two organizations seem to
have addressed that
pretty uh pretty successfully that's the
additional question
is there anything to prevent somebody
from giving
a wealthy donor from giving 200 to every
single
campaign that they chose to do it and
then having
their very substantial contribution
because they will have done it to maybe
hundreds of candidates
uh then you know multiplied by using
uh you know again taxpayer dollars to
the tune of a 1200
match for 200 contributions
well the um there is existing
uh provisions as you know uh to require
disclosure
um and right non-participating
candidates
um the existing disclosure rules would
apply which means that
contributions that total less than 200
dollars would not be
disclosed it's not possible that every
candidate in both
either party or both parties uh could
participate in this program because
there's not going to be enough money
to allow every member of congress to
participate in
in the pilot so the not exactly the
question
i mean the reality is if you've got one
rich guy that'll write a lot of 200
checks uh as opposed to one small donor
that maybe writes one or two
200 checks isn't that going to be
matched
uh by the 1200 and if with all due
respect
if you think those programs uh won't
exist
they will i can assure you each party
will go
find major donors that are willing to
write you know
a hundred thousand dollars worth of 200
checks or
fifty thousand dollars worth of two
hundred dollar check uh and then have
them matched by federal dollars
do you have any concern about that i
don't
candidates need to raise at least at
least fifty thousand dollars from
1 000 small donors at 200
or less i will say that
because it's a pilot and there's a limit
on the amount of money
only a few members i mean i don't know
that it would depend on
uh the number would depend on the
dollars spent in the prior
uh congress and this pilot does not go
into effect
uh immediately uh but
the scenario you outlined has not in
fact been the experience
where uh this has been fried so i guess
i can assure you it will be the
experience let me turn to mr davis
you've you've listened to the dialogue
and get your thoughts
on the workability of this and the
potential for abuse
well i really appreciate uh being able
to respond to this
mr ranking member uh the bill introduced
by our colleague mr sarbanes
that puts this this provision forward
was a disaster when it was a stand-alone
bill it was a disaster
during the last congress when they tried
to to use taxpayer dollars
to create it but then were called out
during our markup process during the
last
congress of hr1 and they changed it
to the first ever corporate dollars
being laundered through the federal
government
to go directly into congressional
campaigns
that's something that we even dove down
further now keep in mind chair lofgren
says
that they may not have enough money in
corporate funds well
mr rankine member you and i both know
congress sets the authorized level of
fines
for people who are who are breaking
federal law
so every chairman and a committee is
going to be incentivized to raise the
fine
level to then be able to put money into
their own campaigns and
and mind you corporations that break the
law
and right now fund things like the
criminals
crime victims assistance fund with these
fines
that now would be taken away to line
members of congress his own
personal campaign coffers are correct
those those things
are going to those dollars
now are going to go into this freedom
from influence fund
so congress sets the level of these
flies so when sheriff lockhart says
we just may not have enough money to get
to the limit
that she mentioned was four million
dollars based upon 2018 numbers
well i got to break it to you i got the
list now the top 20 in 2020.
11 democrats uh nine republicans
but the limit that every member of
congress could then
put into their own campaigns based on
the 50
of the average would be 7.2
million dollars that is something
that the american people are not asking
for
they don't want more money in politics
that's exactly what this provision does
i will see it again and i've said it for
years
my constituents do not want to
have me be able to align my own campaign
coffers
with corporate dollars tax dollars
publicly funded dollars
whatever they want to call it through
this laundry system that they've come up
with
and and enrich my campaign or your
campaigns even more
and anybody who votes for this bill
votes to put more money capped out now
at 7.2 million dollars into their own
personal campaign coffers it's wrong we
can change it by accepting one of
my amendments to strike this language
out and it's one that we're going to
continue to talk about as long as the
majority
continues to lie to the american people
about what this is
let me uh ranking member davis moved to
a different area you actually mentioned
your testimony and that's the changing
of the ballots on the federal election
commission from three to three which
keeps it
you know bipartisan to three to two
uh with no guarantee of a of a
uh chairman and vice chairman of
different parties
uh and and this idea you talked about of
empowering a free speech
and what the dangers of partisanizing
the federal election commission might be
absolutely this is something that i
think every member of congress
republican or democrats should be
concerned about
i don't care for republicans in the
white house i opposed it when
this was brought up in the last congress
under a republican president
and i'll oppose it again we've had
numerous former fec commissioners
write to us and talk to us about how
they solve problems
now the fec has been has been deadlocked
so much so that we have the chair who's
actually about to
about to finish a 20-year career and has
not been confirmed for decades
into her spot that needs to change that
can change at the executive branch level
let's get nominees from both parties to
fill the seats
so that the fec can do their job but to
actually
add a member to make it partisan would
turn the fec
into a partisan organization and right
now
once fully equipped as well now that's
why
i certainly hope that uh president biden
can nominate
fec commissioners to keep it balanced
so that when a decision is made to offer
punishment
or offer any advice to members of
congress running campaigns or anybody
filing under the fec that it's
bipartisan agreement
for punishments rather than just another
partisan
just another partisan commission that
the american people are sick and tired
of
here in washington dc mr cole
i you know i am i just have to say that
the fec is completely dysfunctional at
this point i mean they have
uh they've deadlocked and votes they're
even numbered
and they and they deadlock and uh
there's
increasing deadlocks they couldn't even
agree to hire
a permanent general counsel for more
than seven years
so what we're suggesting is to change it
from a
six-person commission to a
five-per-person commission
and contrary to the ranking member's
suggestion
the we don't want a partisan takeover
of the fec so the provision mandates
that no more than two of the five
commissioners
can be from the same political party no
one
party could take over uh the commission
it also sets up a blue ribbon panel
to help name nominees to the commission
so the nomination process will be more
transparent um you know i just
we can't go on without a referee we've
set up
all these rules that are supposed to be
enforced
and they're never enforced because the
commission can't act
ann rabel who was a member of the
commission who's someone i've known
probably for 35 years she got her start
as a
as in the county council's office when i
was on the board of supervisors in santa
clara county
and she ended up on the fec
as chair and this is what she said it's
worse than
dysfunctional it's the likelihood
of the laws being enforced is slim and
she published a report in 2017
uh showing that there's an increase in
deadlock
votes in the last uh decade we we just
can't like
let this go on and i think that mr cole
thank you for letting me
give my question of course madam chair
absolutely although i
would just say i have a deadlock
commission
that was partisanized and and skeptical
that either party given the opportunity
to effectively have three members
whether it has partisan label on it or
not
are not going to try and tilt that to
their advantage they will
and i think you'll get a succession of
three to two votes that
will sometimes favor republicans and
sometimes favor democrats just depending
on who happens to have
the ability to uh to pack the commission
uh let me move to a different area uh
chair lofgren and
um i know you're aware in 2013 the irs
actually revealed that it selected
primarily conservative organizations for
attentive scrutiny based on their names
and
political positions this led to not only
years of investigations but even a
settlement by the justice department
with more than 400 conservative
non-profits in 2017 in reaction to this
the financial services and general
government appropriations bill has
carried a provision
which would prevent the irs from
implementing new standards that would
allow
for the targeting of conservative groups
yet again this provision
was just recently renewed actually in
the omnibus spending bill last december
uh but this bill actually repeals that
uh
provision um something happened that
makes you think the irs is going to act
more appropriately than it did the last
time it could
use its power in a politically
discriminatory way
well i i'm not sure that's correct mr
cole but obviously
the irs and no other agency of the
federal
government should single out groups for
um enforcement based on their
political views that's un-american and
should never occur
i don't think this changes that and if
you would
uh like to draw my attention to a
provision that you think
does accomplish that i'd be happy to
review it after the hearing
uh please look at section 4501 because
we think that's what it does do and
of course you're exactly right nobody
would want this to happen but the fact
is it did
that's why the justice department had to
settle with 400 different groups that it
discriminated against
let me go to ranking member davis do you
have any concerns that repeal of this
provision
would have a chilling effect on free
speech
absolutely i do uh we all saw what
happened with lopes lerner
during the obama administration when you
put a political hack
in charge of determining who's going to
be granted tax-exempt status they use
they use the politics and the political
persuasions of groups
to deny tax-exempt status it was wrong
then it's wrong now
but this goes back to the the problem
that i see with this entire bill mr
ranking member
that this is another attempt hidden in
now almost
900 pages of legislation it's just
attempt after attempt
to weaken our ability to stay
nonpartisan
you know we go back to the fec now the
problem
isn't that we ought to actually put
make the commission a partisan
commission we all ought to band together
and ask the
executive branch to nominate members i
mean the current
chair is is a regular
tv talk show guest and she
did all she could during the last
administration to show how partisan she
was
against president trump now that's not
what i want to lead a now unbalanced fec
but when you look at the irs this is a
problem look i'm from illinois
and i always said unfortunately a lot of
things in illinois should not be
exported
to washington dc but lois lerner's
behavior weaponizing the bureaucracy
because you have a political agenda
against
free speech is wrong free speech is free
speech
i don't like everything that the other
side says and trust me
did i like the millions of dollars that
were spent in dark money
saying bad things about me during my
last two actually
four out of five campaigns that i've run
in my
50 50 district no but i speak from
experience
and i can say that free speech matters
and when
when we have hundreds of pages
of legislation with uh and i certainly
hope chairperson lofgren takes a look at
that section
and maybe we can work together and amend
this so that the lowest learner rule
is not abolished because we should be
working together
to ensure that no one regardless of what
parties in the executive branch
should ever put a political litmus test
on free speech
let alone tax-exempt status
well thank both of you for your your
fulsome responses madam chair thank you
for
your generosity with the time uh i think
you can see we absolutely
have serious concerns about legislation
i doubt there's going to be
any significant republican support for
it if it stays in its current form
but again thank you for your generosity
with the time and i yield back
well i appreciate the comments and
opinions
of the ranking member um i must say that
you know personally i
disagree with much of what was stated
as it relates to a pilot program
we had a very very extensive
uh debate around that issue it is a
pilot program
it is a volunteer
system to donate into it
should you wish to participate um and
currently i think
um as flawed as uh the federal election
commission
is um you know there is a system
in place to ensure that
politicians or candidates for elected
office
do not enrich themselves or use
political
campaign money for their own personal
uh needs and wants i will offer as an
example a former colleague of ours
whose name should be should not be
publicly
disclosed at this time because all of
you know who i'm talking about
um but he and his wife uh
found themselves in a prison cell as a
result
of misuse of campaign funds
including utilizing it to pay for hotel
rooms to host his mistress
um i'd like to move on though and for
the record
i would like to uh without objection
i'd like to insert into the record this
statement of
administration policy on hr1
and hr 1280 and moving on to
our committee hearing i will now call on
mr
perlmutter for any statement or
questions that he may have
thanks madam chair first thing is i've
got to say i've heard the word
folsom three times today in this hearing
and i don't think i've heard the word
folsom in five years
so i just want to compliment those of
you who've used that word
and uh thank you for that uh second
uh i'm a sponsor of uh both bills so
obviously i support both bills
hr1 and george floyd
justice and policing and with respect to
hr1 for the people
maybe unlike mr davis doesn't want to
export
things from illinois uh to the rest of
the country but i think
we're prepared and we think colorado has
a fantastic
election system uh one that was really
put into place by a
couple of republican secretaries of
state
we have all mail-in balloting we have
my guess is that this year we will have
the highest
uh percentage of voters of anywhere in
the country
in the 18 election we were second to
minnesota in the 16 election we were
second to oregon
and people in the state of colorado take
voting very seriously they exercised
their right
and uh we found uh our voting
our voting uh system to work very well
for democrats republicans unaffiliated
libertarians
green you name it and uh
we would like to see uh that system
anywhere that wants to use it in the
country
because we think it really does empower
americans to exercise their key
right to vote which brings me kind of to
my last point
and i want to thank uh mr davis uh just
looking at
some things here i mean you made a point
you don't want to nationalize
elections that you'd rather see it state
by state and i want to compliment you
in that you didn't sign on to the amicus
brief you didn't vote to decertify
arizona you didn't vote to decertify the
pennsylvania
election but the majority of the
republican party
in the house of representatives did just
that
saying we don't like we didn't like how
pennsylvania conducted
their election we didn't like how
arizona conducted
its election you want to talk about
nationalizing
a process and objecting to a particular
state in the way they've conducted their
affairs
so i just say to my friends and i can't
say it about you mr davis
but i would say to others in your party
don't get on the high horse and object
to nationalizing
elections when
the big lie promulgated by donald trump
and his henchmen
was perpetuated by the votes to
decertify
pennsylvania's election and uh
arizona's election so
with that i'll yield back uh to the
chair
thank you for yelling back i will now
recognize
miss russian dollar
ah thanks jer person
it's okay things are very fluid in
today's society i understand
uh chairman uh running member often
called referred to mr taurus and then
referred to as norma i deeply
apologize sure i've
made making light of the situation it's
all good no offense taken um
uh ranking member davis i just wanted to
go back to the first amendment i know we
were talking about
uh first amendment implications uh with
the fec
but i think it's broader than that could
you expand on first amendment
uh implications of hr1 please
uh thank you uh my colleague and and
let the records show at this time i it
wasn't me hazing you
mr wrestling taller it was the chair of
the committee
um but uh you know sometimes i think the
people that see these
these hearings on tv need to actually
realize we can laugh at each other and
laugh with each other
um you know and i'm actually if i could
go back to something that that mr pearl
mudder said
i noticed that he did not mention that
my raiders beat his broncos twice this
year
i would like for him to admit that on tv
and uh let me know which team was
point of order point of order madam
chair
uh not germaine to the conversation
well hey look i i appreciate the
opinions of
everybody on this panel we are going to
agree
on a lot of issues we're going to
disagree on a lot of issues
but i do know that what works in
colorado
is working because the colorado state
officials and local officials
took the years necessary to implement a
system
that allowed them to succeed in the way
that mr mutter
believes that all others should succeed
but
they got to choose that and they are the
ones
who were able to put this system in
place because the federal government
wasn't telling them how to do it what to
do to implement their system and i would
argue
that states like oregon washington and
colorado that have all vote by mail
programs
that their programs that they as they
currently exist could be hindered
by the implementation of hr1
but free speech is free speech and i
know
that we need to make sure that we do
everything in our power to not weaponize
the bureaucracy like the irs
or any other portion of the federal
government
to limit free speech we may not like
what someone says about us or about our
policies that we support
but frankly i don't like half i don't
like a lot of the things
that people say about uh you know our
view on hr1
but that's that's okay this is part of
the deliberative
legislative process and i'm afraid that
when you implement a speech
czar at the fec that unfortunately
there's going to be
partisan litmus tests put in place and
that's something that we have to guard
against
and we have to make sure that we never
see the irs weaponized
against organizations just simply for
the policies
that they espouse thank you
friends member davis and also um just to
shift gears here
uh what about election security do you
think hr one would make us
more or less susceptible to uh to
foreign interference in our elections
much more susceptible with the uh with
the nationalizing of ballot harvesting a
process that's already been
uh ripe with fraud remember in the last
congress
we did not seat elected republican
members of
a member of congress because the ballot
harvesting
because a process that was illegal in
north carolina was
used that process that this gentleman a
republican operative
used in north carolina would have been
completely legal
in california we introduced a motion to
recommit
during the last congress that would have
made sure that
no foreign interference could have taken
place when it comes to ballot harvesting
and the majority at the time voted
against that motion to recommit
can you imagine if our foreign
adversaries knew that all they needed to
do was go knock on doors
to get ballots of their choice to
influence our election
that's something that we have to be
concerned about and when you nationalize
the process like hr1 does
we run the risk of creating a
nationalized election process
i believe and from talking to election
administrators
across this great country that our
decentralized process
that our constitution uh actually
puts forth for this nation is a much
safer process
we want to make sure that elections
are the safest most secure and we've
invested
together in a bipartisan way over the
last few years hundreds of millions of
dollars
in making sure that we partner with our
states and local
and localities to guard against cyber
security intrusions
it's working it's working well we need
to continue to invest in those measures
but at the same time let's not weaponize
let's not
weaponize by nationalizing the election
process
those adversaries who want to disrupt
our elections
thank you very much davis i appreciate
it with that i would go back to the
chair
you i will now recognize mr raskin
madam chair thank you very much um and
uh
thanks to uh chair lofgren and uh
ranking member davis
for their presentations here um i
i fear that we've gotten lost away in
the
trees and the weeds and we're not
looking at the forest of what
hr one is about this is the most
important
pro-democracy legislation in american
history
since the voting rights act of 1965 as i
read it
and i want to go through what some of
the actual provisions really are
including uh universal automatic voter
registration
so that all citizens get registered
to vote and get to participate because
we should get much closer to those
western democracies where 100 of the
people
uh are participating rather than down
around 50
and so universal voter registration same
day voter registration
uh restoration of voting rights to
former prisoners
is in there the vast majority of states
have already adopted it but i think
um six or seven states still
disenfranchise people permanently if
they've gone to jail or prison
even though they've gotten out and
they've had every other right restored
to them
but they keep denying them uh the right
to vote and we know that there's been a
very big struggle
in florida about this this would restore
the voting rights of former prisoners
the legislation requires the use of
voter verified permanent
paper ballots uh which is something of
concern to people all over the country
um with the introduction of um
of computer uh scanning uh
ballot machines um it also mandates and
this is one of the
major features of legislation to my mind
it mandates the use of
independent redistricting commissions
for uh congressional redistricting to
get away from the gerrymandering
which is destroying the democratic
choice of voters
right now in lots of states the
politicians choose the voters before the
voters choose the politicians
and when we debated this last time i
remember my friend mr davis and i
went back and forth on this where he was
saying well he doesn't want
unelected experts drawing congressional
districts in other words
it seems like our friends in the gop are
favoring politicians drawing their own
districts
um and if i if i got you wrong mr davis
please correct me
why would anybody be against independent
nonpartisan
redistricting panels as opposed to
allowing whatever party happens to be in
control
to draw the districts and thereby
gerrymander
the outcomes in congressional races this
is the difficulty generally
will abolish gerrymandering in
federal congressional elections
yeah you might have me mistaken with
somebody else last time i actually
i said being from illinois i actually
like this provision
because uh illinois is one of the states
that's most guilty
of gerrymandering so i think it might
have me confused with somebody
else i'm delighted to hear that i
then i must have confused with another
member of the house administration
committee who was taking a very strong
position
that unelected people shouldn't be
drawing districts i'll go back and
figure out who that was but i stand
correct mr davidson
i'm thrilled to know that you support
this provision because to my mind
it's one of the central features of hr1
that it will get rid of congressional
gerrymandering
which is so frustrating to people around
the country
politicians should not be drawing their
own districts and i think
we all should be able to agree on a
bipartisan multi-partisan trans partisan
nonpartisan
basis that it's not fair to have people
um pre-determining who their own voters
are going to be so um this also
uh strengthens position uh provisions
related to the
um uh military people serving overseas
and other overseas
voters by requiring that they be sent
absentee ballots uh 45 days
uh before an election um
and uh as well the campaign finance
provisions
um for for the like me i don't
understand
somebody can explain to me this argument
about the free speech tsar but
essentially there are successful
experiments around the country of trying
to get
big private money out of our elections
it's all a question
of who is going to be exercising
exercising influence
over our legislative bodies and over our
legislators
and if what we say is that people with
big money are going to be able to call
the shots
then we know we get something much more
like plutocracy than democracy
so these matching fun systems say you go
out and you get a bunch of
small donors to contribute small amounts
of money
and then once you've demonstrated your
seriousness as a candidate
at that point we make a public
investment that's where we get you know
all of the
rhetoric about you know the federal
government giving money to politicians
the question is who do you want to own
the political agenda do you want big
private donors who put the money in
or do you want to say we'll have a
matching system where
the public will take over and then we
can oust
the big money um you know the the big
money puppeteers
from our politics so i think that these
systems
i've seen them in maine in arizona
in new york city uh we've got one in
montgomery county maryland
these systems are working to liberate
politicians from having to
essentially do the bidding of the
biggest donors
um and you know if there are ways to
make elections cheaper i'm all for that
mr davis i'm with you on it but let's
not say
um you know that well elections are too
expensive now and this will just make
them more expensive the question is
who's paying for the campaigns and who
are the politicians
uh beholden to i think like that becomes
the the critical question so um
you know there may be things that should
be adjusted but i can't
for the letting me understand why
anybody would oppose this comprehensive
pro-democracy pro-voting rights package
and um but let me start with you mr
davis because you you raised the point
about
a free speech czar and you're speaking
to somebody who's actually gotten
the annual award of the aclu for um
uh for standing up for free speech okay
uh
and i would put my record up against
anybody uh
in congress and maybe there's people can
beat me as a free speech advocate
but i am a big champion of free speech
so if you could tell me what that's all
about
then you caught my attention mr davis
yeah well i'm i'm glad you got the award
from the aclu
you might not get it this year for your
support of hr one last time
um i expect them to oppose this bill
once again
but the speech jar is referenced in
section 6003
of your bill i would urge you to to take
a look at those provisions
uh but also it's called the speech zar
uh that's what it's basically what it
creates you can call it what you want
but it
okay well the reason i guess it didn't
the reason i didn't notice it it wasn't
called the speech star so what are you
doing
it doesn't matter what something's
called if that's the end result
um that's what you have and as a matter
of fact
as we look at the independent
redistricting commissions
did you go back to this problem that we
have
in in this entire bill if dc
democrats in the majority that will set
the agenda and set the policies
look i'm for independent redistricting
commissions in states like illinois
but what's going to work are we going to
have washington d.c
and the majority democrats in congress
be the ones to set these policies
because you mentioned
you mentioned mr raskin that the six to
one match program
is something that would take the control
of money
out of the hands of of people here in
america
but what you don't mention sir is that
it will then be in the hands
of everyone in this institution because
it's
congress that continues to set the
levels of these corporate fines
that this bill puts in place that gets
laundered through a process
through the taxpayers and into
congressional campaigns
at the same time that money is not
going that money is not going to be
reduced
it's going to add to the ever increased
political spending that we see if you
look at just what chairperson locker
mentioned
from 2018 to 2020 the eligible amount
that a candidate that all of us on this
call
could have gotten put into our campaign
coffers if you meet
a threshold that many of us in targeted
races have already met
we could have put over four million
dollars directly into our campaigns
in the last congress but because of the
exponential rise in the ability of small
dollar
donors to participate freely in our
election process
that new cap was raised in 2020 to 7.2
million dollars
don't think that that's not going to
continue to go up and it's going to
create a beast
that is going to be self-regulated and
self-funded
by congress every time a committee in a
law is to raise
corporate fines this would be the first
ever corporate money
going directly into our campaigns since
1907. well wait that's not
true okay i'm going to come to miss lost
but let me just say this because
i i don't want to confuse people out
there there's a supreme court decision
called citizens united
which opened the floodgates on corporate
money coming into our politics so
when you keep saying that it's the first
time in many times
since 1907 it goes directly into
our reelects our congressional campaigns
you know mr raskin as well as i we
cannot accept
okay this would be corporate money
all right let me just reclaim my time
for a second because if your point is
that the citizens united decision
was wrongly rendered then we're a
thousand percent together on it to me
it's a complete distortion of what a
corporation is a corporation exists for
economic purposes
and that's why it has all of the
advantages of perpetual life in limited
liability
in bankruptcy production and so on
that's what a corporation is it should
not be involved in politics as justice
white
once said that the corporation is the
creature of the state and the state
need not permit its own creature to
devour it to consume it okay
that's the situation we're in but hr one
is trying to deal with that problem
hr1 has a whole set of provisions
designed to
get foreign corporate money out of our
elections
so that corporations are not used as a
vehicle for
funneling foreign money into american
campaigns that's what hr one is trying
to do and we've seen this
over the last several years terrible
corruption
of the process of foreign money uh which
is illegal foreign national money which
is illegal in our elections
coming to corporations because the
corporations
are allowed to have foreign stock owners
and
foreign uh you know agents and
for foreign officers and so on there are
provisions in hr1
to try and deal with that problem okay
and so
but i would think if you're a critic of
citizens united which sounds like you
may be
you should be absolutely for hr1 i want
to make sure that
before i go to ms washington that in
something you just said did you just
retract your support for the
redistricting
uh commission provisions in this
i'm for independent redistricting
commissions and that's something you and
i agreed on during the last markup so
you support support
however uh i will not support the
provisions as written without
some ins without being able to actually
have a voice
in how much control congress is going to
have in setting
states abilities congress has no control
congress just requires it mandates that
there be independent registering
commissions but it's up to the state
to set it up so i cert i certainly hope
that i certainly hope that we can come
up with a plan that illinois and
maryland can work on together
but i do want to it's called hr one
that's the one that all the states are
working on together it's called
big it's vague and it's not going to be
able to set up the commission
you and i both envisioned but i would
like to say on citizens united mr raskin
that it did not permit corporate dollars
or foreign dollars
to come into our election that was not
the citizens united decision
but your solution your is
to this alleged foreign interference and
corporate dollars coming in
to america is to shut down that type of
that type of organization but instead
wander those same
okay well look i i may stand corrected
on being standing on on uh having stood
corrected before because it sounds like
you just retracted your support for the
provisions uh
in this bill which actually
do mandate independent redistricting
commissions i hope that you would
continue
to support them or at least decide to
support them
because this is a major problem and a
major threat to democracy
when we have politicians you know
setting up their own districts this is
our opportunity to do it
right now in h1 this is our chance to
deal with it otherwise you know it's
very difficult as you know
whether the republicans are in control
or the democrats in control
to get any state to unilaterally disarm
and say
we will move away unless you've got the
initiative provision and the initiative
then you can override what the state
legislature is doing
uh but i do believe there are people in
your party not you
but there people in your party who made
the calculation that the republicans are
gerrymandering in a lot more states
because they control more state
legislatures than democrats are
and so they're not interested in
national reform and that's where the
rhetoric goes
you know growth states rights come from
in this very specific
context even when we've got as mr
perlmutter uh
says this this amazing effort that all
these members of congress just signed on
to
to try to thwart and nullify election
results
in particular states which a number of
members just said that that just goes
way too far
for me when you're trying to throw out
certified election results particularly
i look at ms lofton let me come to you
okay
first of all can you clarify is there a
speech
that is in hr1 because i couldn't find
it anywhere
that's because there is none um there
have been
criticism uh about the role of the
fec chair who was permitted to do
administrative tasks under the bill
but any uh enforcement efforts uh or
policy matters
would need a vote of the commission just
as they do today
so it really is incorrect to suggest
that there's some individual who's going
to do all the enforcement
by himself or herself and to suggest
that enforcing
the disclosure laws is somehow against
free speech
i think it's simply incorrect if you
take a look and i
you know i did not agree with the
citizens united
uh decision but what you know it's the
law of the land because uh
you know agree with it or not it's what
the court said
um but the decision
itself said the remedy was disclosure
um you know i believe it was justice
kennedy who
talked about the need and along with
seven other justices
and this is what he said the first
amendment protects political speech
and disclosure permits citizens and
shareholders to react to the speech
in a proper way so while they unleashed
limitless money by saying that limitless
money
uh was equivalent to speech the remedy
was disclosure and we've never enacted
the disclosure that they called for
we finally would do so in hr1 in fact
going all the way back to buckley versus
vallejo in 1976
the bipartisan commitment i think of
congress
and of the supreme court was to say that
well whether or not you thought there
should be limits on contributions or
expenditures
everybody agrees that disclosure is
perfectly permissible within the first
amendment
and that was part of buckley and again
it was part of citizens united with
justice kennedy's opinion as you say
and now suddenly we're getting this
attack on disclosure requirements
as compulsory speech or a violation of
the first amendment and
you turn the the chair of the fec to his
speech czar
that's a speech doctor who can't even
call a meeting of the
fec because it's set up for complete
dysfunction let me go to that question
for a second don't most federal agencies
and commissions have an odd number of
members yes
yes for an obvious reason so they don't
deadlock
right so that they can actually get
something done and also so it doesn't
encourage partisan thinking it's not
like well there's this team on this side
and that team on that side
but there's an odd number of people who
can actually operate
and each one is is encouraged to use his
or her mind
so now we've got the fec which is set up
like
you know a deadlocked town council
between
three democrats and three republicans
and so the whole point of moving to an
odd number is to get away
from that kind of partisan mentality in
gridlocking to
allow the fec to operate it's just a
huge waste of money to have millions of
dollars
going into the federal election
commission with their staff with the
members and so on and they can't even
meet
and they can't render decisions isn't
that right yes
and i think it's important to note on
the disclose act
in terms of corporate spending if the
disclose act requires disclosures
for groups that spend ten thousand
dollars or more
on campaign uh ads and
it only requires a disclosure of donors
who give ten thousand
or more you know some have said well
that would be a
problem people don't want to know how
they're spending their money
uh it would catch people who are
uninvolved in this
there's a way to make sure that only the
politically active
donors are disclosed and that's by
making campaign related disbursements to
a segregated bank account
so that the organization doesn't have to
disclose
any donations that were not from the
segregated bank account um
you know the idea that dark money is
good for the democracy i think most
americans will disagree with and i know
that i do i'd like to just say something
else because there's been a lot of
discussion
about whether it's
proper or in his opening statement the
ranking member even said
constitutional for the federal
government
to assert itself in these elections and
i think
here's what article 1 section 4 says it
says
the times places and manner of holding
elections where senators and
representatives shall be
prescribed in each state by the
legislature thereof but
the congress may at any time
by law make or alter such regulations
that's what hr one is doing we are
saying
that in these areas where we're seeing
republican
legislatures primarily going to
pass laws to prevent americans from
being able to cast their vote
that that is not acceptable uh in and we
are going to
buy law regulation change that
so that eligible voters in the united
states can cast their vote
and i think it's a little disingenuous
to complain about that
because uh the republican study group
or study committee earlier this year
endorsed something called the slave
democracy act
now what would that bill do it would
establish national standards
that would prohibit automatic voter
registration
that would make it harder to cast a
ballot and would impose
restrictive rules on vote tabulation so
i guess it's okay
for the federal government to use the
second
phrase of article 1 section 4 if it's to
restrict ballot access
but not okay if it helps every american
cast a ballot
i want to just closed with with two
points one
would the gentleman yield for yes by all
means mr call of course
thank you very much uh my friend uh just
for the record bill i did not say
anything about constitutionality of
fetish i just
reviewed my statement so mr davis being
clear
okay mr d says the ranking member so
maybe i misunderstood you mean you're
right
a lot of ranking members remember the
house administration members thank you
very much
just wanted to have the record to
reflect that thank you
um we tried not to contradict our own
ranking member
on the rules committee thank you mr cole
so look
we haven't talked about the ethics
provisions that are in here because it's
not just about
voting and administration of voting uh
and campaign finance it's also about
ethics and there are some sweeping
important ethics provisions in here for
example
on presidential conflicts of interest
something we've all gotten to know
something about
uh over the last four years this
provision in subtitle b of title eight
requires the president and vp
within 30 days of taking office to to
divest
all financial interests that pose a
conflict of interest
uh and to disclose information about any
business interest
i mean this to my mind was the original
sin
of the last administration that the
president upon
taking office instead of saying he was
going to divest himself
from hundreds of business interests and
corporations from around the world
said he was just going to keep them
going and so
we totally mixed private self-enrichment
and profit-making
with the business of government white
house
ethics transparency is in here requiring
executive branch ethics waivers
to be disclosed to the office of
government ethics and to the public
because this is the people's government
so we have a right to know
what's going on with people who are in
office ethics for the
transition team that we get information
about the roles of the members of the
transition team
to make sure that they are free of
conflicts of interest
and then a whole set of ethics reforms
relating to us
to congress including very significantly
prohibiting members of congress
from serving on for-profit business
corporation
boards why are members of congress
who have taken a pledge to
preserve and to uphold the constitution
against all enemies foreign and domestic
and to fight for the common good why
would we be serving
on for-profit corp boards
can we not all agree as a matter across
lines of party
geography ideology and everything that
we
we have got to make sure that our
values are lined up
with devotion to the people and zealous
pursuit of the public interest i just
think
that's absolutely critical um it also
prohibits members of congress from using
taxpayer funds
to settle cases of employment
discrimination um
that are brought against members so
somebody sued for sex discrimination or
sexual harassment or whatever it
might be we should not be using
government money
to settle those suits um
so i like that very much right and let
me just say
finally uh that back on the question of
citizens united which really
has fundamentally changed the character
of politics in our country by opening
the floodgates on corporate spending
in american politics um there's a
provision in hr1
uh which i introduced separately as a
bill which i
i called shareholders united which says
okay if the premise of citizens united
by justice kennedy is that the
corporation is speaking for the
shareholders
and they're the ones who have first
amendment rights because corporations
don't
have first amendment rights that belongs
to people but the idea is it's well it's
derivative of the rights of the
shareholders
well then no corporation should be able
to spend any money
in politics without first getting a
majority vote of the shareholders
themselves
again i think that's something that cuts
totally across party lines ideological
lines
geographic lines that corporations
should not be involved in politics in
any way until first you've gotten a vote
by the shareholders that they want their
money to be spent
in that way another really critical
feature of uh
hr one so uh madame chair i've forgive
me
for going on for so long but i just
think this is really important
legislation
uh if i have if i find any fault with it
it's that it's packed with too much good
stuff
and people don't understand everything
that's in there we've got a
responsibility to try to educate people
about the different pieces from the
universal automatic
voter registration to the getting big
money out of our politics to getting
foreign corporate money
out of our politics to all of these
ethics provisions this
is sweeping pro-democracy pro-public
integrity legislation
and i'm thrilled to be able to support
it and i yield back to you
thank you mr raskin and while
the rules committee has a very liberal
policy of
ensuring that members and our guests
are able to articulate you know their
opinions
and priorities i will respectfully ask
that
folks do not try not to speak over each
other
so with that i am going to recognize
miss
uh fishbach
thank you madam chair uh you know first
i just i feel like i should just mention
that um
this is another bill that is going to
the floor
uh without a committee markup and uh and
continually
uh i hear well we had a hearing last
year we had a hearing last year well as
a freshman
and uh there are 62 freshmen this year
none of us were afforded the opportunity
to see these in committee and so i would
like to just point that out to the
majority
that there there are members about 15
percent
of the members have not had the
opportunity to deal with these so
continuing to bring these to the floor
is just
without any committee hearings this year
just seems to
um totally disregard that the freshmen
are are
allowed any input but um i just wanted
to
um ask ranking member davis you know a
piece of this bill
would allow for a private right of
action against
a locality if voters wait more than 30
minutes
this does not uh to be it does not
appear to be a well-conceived idea and
would
be particularly burdensome in a district
like mine where
uh rural small rural counties and
townships um
and i wanted to just give you the
opportunity to expand on any of those
additional requirements that would be
mandated by bureaucrats in washington
d.c
that would be problematic for the folks
in my district
thank you miss fischbach and welcome to
the rules committee uh
obviously no one told you what the rules
committee was going to be like
um i spent a lot of time in here aren't
you uh but no
well ranking member they don't tell you
until you agree to do it
then they tell you well you know what
actually uh
some of the members on both sides of the
aisle are are very good friends and uh
you're with good
good folks and we need this debate which
is why i'm glad to be here
uh glad to put forth our differences and
one difference i have is in the
provision that you mentioned
i'll go to my home county my voting
experience in 2020
my county clerk is a democrat he
actually was one of my witnesses and
remember
in the minority we have very few
hearings uh in house administration
we had very few during the last congress
and i get
one witness and i chose a democrat
elected official
because i know mike janazi back in my
hometown of taylorville in christian
county illinois
he doesn't care about if you're
republican or democrat he wants
elections to go off without a hitch
mike came and testified about the impact
of this top down approach
and what it would have on him and his
ability to implement elections
in my district in my home county my my
election precinct well this time
when i voted in the general election i
voted early i went in on a saturday
morning
and i watched mike and his employees who
were there at the courthouse
in a county my hometown's uh a little
under 12 000 people and i had to wait
that day on a saturday morning 25 missed
a vote
well would it have gone faster if we
didn't have
coveted and mike was going in between
every voter and cleaning each machine
or voting area that he had put together
to properly have social distancing
and make sure he limited the risk of any
coverage spread of course
but what are you gonna do if that would
have gone five minutes longer for me
if one more person would have been in
line are we going to have people
that are that are there with are we
going to poll watchers with stop watches
and they're going to have private rights
of action that will be could be
politically motivated as to where they
stand
and where they begin to to actually put
forth
these different uh violations of timing
it's wrong it's wrong to have this top
down approach let's let democrats like
mike gennazi
in christian county illinois determine
how best
to safely administer their elections
because i can tell you from my own
experience
one more voter one more family walking
into that
courthouse that day before me i would
have gone over your timeline
that's being set by democrats in
washington d.c
not by democrats in christian county
this
this this also this bill mandates the
use of drop boxes
it requires 15 days and 10 hours a day
of early voting
even in all mail states i mean this is
the provision that my colleague mr pearl
mudder
should be concerned about because it can
disrupt the successful vote by mail
programs
that you have in colorado ad on other
unfunded mandates
this is what i'm concerned about while
there are provisions that we can work on
agreeing together
like i would love for an independent
commission for redistricting
bill to be put forth on its own let's
sit down mr raskin
to talk about where we agree let's see
if we can come up with a plan
to introduce this on its own rather than
being paired with these unfunded
mandates
this top-down approach also without
being pair
paired with policies that will put money
into my own campaign
in your own campaign now if ms fischbach
if you would uh
if you wouldn't mind i'd like to address
some of the issues that mr raskin
brought up
during his questions when it comes to
constitutional law look i'm not a
constitutional attorney
like my colleague mr raskin but
i my interpretation of the constitution
says that you know some policies may be
good ideas
um you know just as i mentioned we don't
want anybody to wait in long lines
but the constitution simply does not
permit congress
to mandate these issues states and
localities must be involved
that's what the constitution requires my
interpretation
i would rather again have democrats like
mike genesee in my home county
setting how he's going to administer the
elections
and make sure that everybody has a
chance to vote
we mentioned the fec and the speech jar
i do believe
that this new fec chair empowered by a
partisan advantage
will become a free speech czar the goal
of the fec is not to get things done
it's if if they overreach they actually
can
impact our citizens rights to free
speech and we also
you know we also heard from my colleague
mr raskin
when it comes to disclosure the
disclosure of campaign spending is great
i'm all for it we do it our
congressional campaigns have to disclose
donors above
a certain level and we all do that
we want that but since the
decision in 1958 the naacp
the alabama we have never required
donors
to issue groups to be disclosed
you can understand why the naacp brought
this suit in 1958
don't you i do why in the world would we
then
weaponize the same processes that were
used
in 1958 against african americans when
they were exercising
and groups like the naacp were
exercising their right
to free speech these are the concerns i
have with this bill among the many
others
i look forward to working with my
colleagues in a bipartisan way
if given the chance but remember as you
mentioned
miss fishbach there was no markup you
were not
able to have your voice be heard at our
committee hearings
because you weren't here but let's not
forget
that this original bill was written
in the written with the aid of outside
special interest groups
in at the end of the election cycle in
2018
was introduced on january 3rd of
2019 and co-sponsored by every member of
the majority party
they didn't read it they wrote it with
special interest groups in the
in the darkness and that's something
that this bill is supposed to change
i'm not convinced that the majority has
learned their lesson because they took
that same bill
added pages to it but then they
subtracted some provisions
i'm glad my colleague mr raskin brought
up the ethics reforms in this bill
it's interesting to know that they've
actually been relaxed a little bit from
the version
in the last congress to this congress
could that be because there's a
different
party in power in the white house a
different president
i don't know i didn't get a chance to
write it
and and ranking member davis if i could
just follow up just a little bit
uh regarding the um the top down
approach and who wrote the bill and
and i and i understand that the majority
didn't discuss the bill with the
stakeholders which would be
the national association of the
secretary of state the national
association of states uh
election directors the national
association of counties and ncsl
and and the gentleman that you mentioned
from your hometown
but don't you you know if why wouldn't
they talk to those folks because i think
that some of this uh
top-down uh kind of approach could have
been addressed and
and they would have understood better
but um
you know who did they talk to uh and and
why wouldn't they talk to those folks
that actually have to
implement these policies i mean i think
that's a question for the majority i i'd
like to know if
you know why these groups weren't
consulted by some of the impression
there was some
concern on a bipartisan call with the
secretaries of state and other election
officials
uh just a few days ago multiple
secretaries of state
and election officials have reached out
to me this is why our only witness
in the only hearing where i got five
minutes of questions and
my two other colleagues on house admin
got five minutes of questions
for these witnesses so 15 minutes of
republican minority questions
are now going to suffice for a markup
and
this mammoth bill coming forward
there were many issues brought up during
our hearing that even some of the
democratic witnesses
at a recent hearing they noted that
multiple provisions in this bill
need to be amended now the drafters of
this legislation they were so
sloppy in writing this bill they utterly
failed to understand the complexity
of america's local government systems
and our decentralized
election administration system they
forgot that north dakota
doesn't even have voter registration in
maine
elections are run by municipalities not
counties
and that multiple states have as
colorado
does full vote by mail systems we're
mandating
in-person absentee voting absentee
voting
would be a step backwards so that's the
problem with the top-down approach that
many
election administrators and secretaries
of state have reached out to us
to say we don't want the in washington
that control congress
telling us how to run our election cycle
and i'd certainly hope
some of my colleagues would agree with
some of their election officials
and um madam chair um if i might
um maybe uh chair laughrin would like to
address that why weren't those
groups um why weren't those groups
talked to
and allowed to have him put into the
bill
well as i'm sure mr davis will recall we
did have
representatives from state election
officials as witnesses
in the last congress and we just as
recently as last week
had a secretary of state as well as a
local
election official as a witness i do want
to say
a clarification mr davis you probably
were not aware
that the provisions taken out of the
ethics
portion of the bill were only taken out
because they have since become
law and therefore it would be redundant
to put them in a bill since they were
enacted into law
already and that's the only reason why
they're not
uh included i thought it was important
to clarify that
you're muted still unmuted i'm sorry i
was trying to
reduce the back uh extra noise but
um chair lochran could you summarize the
difference between the two managers
amendments for me
i understand that one version was
introduced a day
a few days ago and there was a newer
longer version that was
introduced today and i would appreciate
having a better understanding of the
differences
yes the manager's amendment makes
several technical and conforming
edits to hr1 that's as commonly
uh done it includes
augmenting the section on findings of
general constitutional authority
and clarifying the standards for
judicial review
the amendment requires mail-in ballots
to use the postal service
barcode service as required in the
vote-by-mail tracking act
introduced by representative carolyn
maloney the chairperson of the
government oversight and government
reform committee
it also clarifies that the definition of
a thing of value
in the federal election campaign
prohibition on foreign donations to
political campaigns
and candidates includes information
sought or obtained
for lit for political advantage it
strikes
section 4411 which is related to the
inadmissibility and deportability of
aliens
engaged in improper interference in u.s
elections since that is already
covered in the immigration and
nationality act the amendment
updates the findings reaffirming the
commitment of congress to
restore the voting rights act and it
also clarifies
that the redistricting reform provisions
of hr1
apply to redistricting following the
2020
dicennial census and provides clear
procedures
for drawing maps for this truncated
timeline
due to the delay in the census data now
these updates
include an amendment offered by
congressman
g k butterfield the chairman of the
election subcommittee
and the house administration committee
which would require states to submit the
final
district plan approved by the state's
independent redistricting commission
to the department of justice for
administrative review before it could be
enacted although that review will be
suspended
if litigation is initiated pursuant to
the statute i hope that clarifies
we also added pardon me a um
a section on the governance of corporate
tax
allowing the commission to collect
information to assess the governance
of corporate pacs and requiring the fec
to do an analysis of donors
thank you thank you thank you very much
and i would just like to
give ranking member davis the
opportunity to maybe respond to some of
those
items if he has if he has things he'd
like to address
yeah the provisions regarding the ethics
rules that are
that have been relaxed and are not law
are addressed in my good friend and
colleague
ranking member comer's amendment
amendment number 154
um if the majority is willing to work
with us
to uh to rule that amendment order and
support that i'm
i'm more than willing to to put that
forth and
there was also mentioned earlier that
some republicans have offered amendments
that
chairperson lofgren believes you know
would nationalize the election process
i'm not a co-sponsor of that amendment
not a co-sponsor of that bill
i am speaking as clear and concisely as
i have been
every single time that the house
administration committee
and the majority here in congress have
tried to nationalize our election
process
that we need to stop it and
i continue to to hope that we can find
some common ground on
ways to make our processes safer
continue to hope
that we can work together on making sure
that we have
systems in place voluntary systems in
place that will
allow for areas that i believe
are at risk when it comes to cyber
security like e-pull books
voter registration lists let's work
together to make sure
that those data systems are secure just
like the standards that are in place for
electronic voting systems
that we currently have through the
election assistance commission
thank you madam chair i yield back thank
you i will now recognize ms scanlan
thank you madam chair
um i'm i'm so glad to hear that uh
representative davis is
less interested now in nationalizing our
elections because i know he
was very interested in conducting
national oversight of the five largest
democratic counties in pennsylvania
during the last election and and also
uh wasn't happy with our electoral
college folks
but um as to hr1
um you know i've spent the last three
decades working to protect the right to
vote and expand voter participation for
all eligible voters you know with civics
education
so having spent so much time up close
and personal particularly in
pennsylvania which has been a target
of so many voter suppression efforts in
the last
year in particular but in the last
decade as well
it shows me how important hr one is not
to dictate to the states but to set a
floor to which they have to
rise um you know we've seen modern voter
suppression tactics the influence of
dark money to promote disinformation
gerrymandering and other democratic
anti-democratic
practices that have disenfranchised
voters
um and as i mentioned in pennsylvania
we've seen that
up close in 2011 the republican
legislature and republican governor of
pennsylvania
passed a gerrymandering of pennsylvania
which despite the fact that we had
a large
democratic majority of registered voters
produced
18 congressional seats of which 13 went
to republicans
in 2018 that system had to be undone
it was only undone because the courts
declared that gerrymandering to be
so unconstitutional but it was depriving
people
of their vote okay
in 2012 the republican legislature and
the republican governor
passed a strict voter id law which
discriminated against voters of color
the elderly and low-income voters again
the courts had to overturn that
because it was the it limited the
forms of identification that were
acceptable to
um those which were not readily
acceptable to a certain class of voters
who happened overwhelmingly to be
democrats
so we need at the federal level to make
sure that those who are
eligible to vote in our federal
elections
are in fact able to exercise that
essential freedom
to participate in our representative
democracy
so um
chairwoman um lofgren can you talk about
that
interplay between our federal and our
state uh
elections and how hr1
performs in that gap in a constitutional
way
well as you know the voting rights act
of 1965
was a very important step forward for
the united states
in preserving uh the rights of
especially minorities
uh to vote and exercise the franchise
prior to that
measure um african americans
in the south in particular were subject
to poll taxes
were excluded from their rights as
american citizens to vote that
that those measures were very much uh
rooted
in the 14th amendment but
the need to preserve the rights of all
americans to vote
is not just it is to protect
um minorities in this country in h.r
for the voting rights act
to the john lewis voting rights act will
be coming before the floor
later in this congress mr butterfield as
chair of the election subcommittee
has outlined an aggressive
schedule of hearings to do further
an investigation and further compilation
of the statistical basis for the need
of that provision but discriminating
against americans
right to vote is not only based on
ethnicity it can be based on excessive
partisanship
it can be and which is we see rampantly
going on
all over the united states article 1
section 4
gives congress the right as you say at
any time
to by law to make or alter the
regulations
and what we're saying is let's have a
fair vote
there there were people voters in
georgia
in the last election in november that
had to wait in line for eight hours
to get into the polling booth do you
think that everyone
who had a right to vote actually got to
vote
in that line because some of them had
kids they had to get back to that they
were getting out of school
or they had to get back to their job
there were people in
other parts of the country who had to
drive for three hours
to get to a drop box to deposit a ballot
do you think everybody
who had a right to vote really was able
to
exercise their franchise no and so i say
this
let's have every american cast their
vote
and whatever they decide is what we live
with
you know whoever the candidate is
whoever the party is i'm willing to
trust the american people
and the vote that they cast and and to
say that this is partisan
that's ridiculous it's partisan only if
you think of all the people vote
your side will lose um i don't know
who wins uh when everybody votes but i
do know this
america wins when everybody votes and
that's what hr one does
thank you one more question for you um
you know people talk a lot about
partisanship and i know when we're all
home we hear
from our constituents saying you know
can't you all get along and how can
congress work in my more bipartisan way
and what i read and the experts seem to
suggest
is that one of the issues is
gerrymandering because if people
only are running in safe seats and
they're only really
if they get to pick their own voters and
and these seats are
are pre-ordained by party that increases
the partisanship can you talk about the
gerrymandering aspects of
anti-gerrymandering aspects of hr1
well it it requires a nonpartisan
redistricting commission that is made up
uh
from people who are not politicians uh
who have to do the following things
first you have to make sure that the
districts comply
with the u.s constitution basically one
person one vote
and then they need to implement the
provisions of the voting rights act of
1965.
they need to provide that racial ethnic
and language minorities
have an equal opportunity to participate
in the political process
not dilute or diminish their ability to
elect candidates
of their choice they have to be have
boundaries that
minimize the division of communities of
interest
and shouldn't be drawn to unduly favor
or disfavor
any political party uh you know we've
seen the situation
you know all of us if we're honest know
that there are
um elected officials in both parties
that only have to cater to the fringe
because everything is done in the
primary and the more extreme you
are no matter which party you're in uh
the easier it is politically i don't
know that that's
a great thing for the united states and
i think most people most americans
would say we're not in the best place
as a country in terms of partisanship
and
being able to find common ground and
partisan gerrymandering is a big part
of that of that phenomena
if we have more competitive districts we
have more
capacity to reach out to all americans
not just a few and to find common ground
to move our country forward so
a number of states have these
commissions
they've had a positive impact in getting
people
uh to a better spot and i'll say both
parties you know if they have if they
control the legislature both parties do
gerrymandering
so uh you know and it in its
perverse in every case let's stop it
let's have citizens pick the districts
instead of the politicians
picking the voters i think that's right
i think it's also kind of a uniquely
um federal spin of h.r 1 that we've seen
a number of states like arizona and
california and other states
moved to having the citizens commission
and being
happier with the results finding the
results more accurately reflecting their
population
we found the same thing in pennsylvania
although it had to be forced
by the courts because the legislature
refused to do that
um i i am really excited about hr one
and and very happy to support it i'm
particularly proud that i
have some bills in it to increase access
for voters uh with disabilities to bring
transparency to inaugural funds because
we've seen some abuses there
to increase the use of ballot drop boxes
which were critical to getting out the
vote in pennsylvania this last time
and i'm also hopeful to have an
amendment to increase early access
to voting on college campuses because
we've seen some of the
college campuses in my region and i have
19
be subject to voter suppression by
having polling places removed
so i'll proudly support this legislation
and with that i would yield back
thank you mr morelli
thank you uh madam chair and uh i don't
want to repeat
but would like to associate myself with
the remarks made by
my colleagues um mr raskin ms scanlon
uh yourself mr pearl mudder although i
don't have an opinion i'm sort of
agnostic on the use of the word folsom
and i know how i feel about the broncos
but other than that um
this has really been a really important
conversation i
i will say this i'm not going to go on
at length but
i feel and this is with all due respect
to uh to my colleagues on the other side
of the aisle
but to talk about fair elections and
election reform
um and to talk about federal
intervention after we have just
witnessed over the last several months
in my view
the most serious threat to the
foundations of american democracy
which is to not respect the peaceful
transfer of power
to not respect uh that fair free
elections should matter in this country
uh
has left i think my friends on the other
side of the aisle in the awkward
position
of not supporting fair elections and
then trying to somehow suggest
that our efforts to continue to approve
the electoral process
are off-base or unnecessary particularly
federal
involvement um you know without
recounting it but
60 lawsuits aimed at overturning an
election
all deemed to be baseless um
this continued claim even by the former
president this weekend
that the election was stolen although
there is
zero evidence not a single shred of
evidence that there was a systemic
or systematic effort uh or
or no without a shred of evidence that
there was any fraud that was done on a
systematic way
um and to continue to undermine the very
foundations
i i can't imagine a more serious topic i
can't imagine one
and this isn't just respectfully a
handful
of republican members who objected to
the certification
um this is two-thirds of the caucus
objected to it this is
um something we haven't seen in the
better part of two centuries
uh happen in american politics in 1800
john adams made what i think is one of
the greatest acts of patriotism in this
country
he turned over the keys to the white
house thomas jefferson
and that's something that we have
observed now for the better for
more than two centuries and yet um
i i hate to think of what would have
happened um
if just a few elections had gone a
different way this year
um so i i think this is a very very
serious thing are there things that
could be improved in this
are there ways we probably could if we
had good faith
on both sides come together to improve
this i don't doubt that there
there are but i think the credibility
now
with my colleagues on the other side of
the aisle is very much lacking
i i think you can always come to a place
of bipartisanship
and you can always improve and you can
always work things out you can always
talk about
if you operate in good faith and i just
honestly and it pains me because i have
many many friends
on the other side of the aisle and i
obviously represent
uh hundreds of thousands of republicans
back home
it pains me to say the leadership of the
party has in a sense
seated all moral right to have a
conversation
about this issue and until you have a
significant number of republicans
acknowledge that joe biden is the
president of the united states
won the election in a fair election
process and
the idea that somehow the people in
georgia the republican officials in
georgia
who spoke out repeatedly
and took some offense at the president's
language
and the many republican officials in
pennsylvania and yet you objected to the
certification when we talk about states
rights
that'd be fine if we actually respected
those states but we didn't do it
um and in my mind this is the single
biggest threat to american democracy as
i said since the civil war
uh and until uh there is some indication
that we're going to all respect
uh the the right of voters as the
sovereign in this nation
voters citizens americans the sovereign
there's no king
there's no queen the sovereign of the
people they spoke
and yet your party two-thirds of the
members of your caucus and i certainly
would not um bring everyone into it some
of you in my mind
demonstrate great courage in in standing
for the electoral college and the will
of citizens but until
it's embraced by more members i think
any conversation about this
frankly is and sadly uh is
is of little use so with that uh mr
chair madam chair i uh yield back
thank you mr desonia
you're a mute mr desanie
thank you i am fulsomely unmuted
um and i want to associate myself with
all the comments except perhaps
those directed at mr permalter with
affection
i also want to say that i i consider
both ranking members uh friends
a good deal of respect for them so these
uh
comments um i'll be take in that regard
and i have to say i feel a little bit
like
alice in wonderland again and of course
who the mad hatter is is
based on the viewers perception um
and uh mr davis i congratulate you i
think you've
entered a a new part of the political
lexicon
in uh speech czars that from my
perspective will join
um death panels uh but
i just this is so important and uh
you know in the history of this country
trying to make sure that power is
really in the hands of the voters has
been a challenge in this country you
know
of course our mythology is that uh it's
been a great
um accomplishment and
unfortunately i think we have to accept
the shortcomings we've had in this
country that are obvious
in order to get to the point where we do
have
greater participation so according to
pew uh we are
24th out of 35 developed countries
in voter participation i don't exactly
think
that's a city on the hill type of thing
that other countries are going to follow
with eu you
think that expression is from the bible
reagan or winthrop
so this is all at a time and this is why
i think this bill is so important
and having been part of redistricting at
both the local and state level
um i just think there are three things
that clearly we have a conflict of
interest
uh in regards to and that's our
compensation
um our districts and uh
campaign contributions um and i
in the ten years since citizens united
uh we've gone from
300 million dollars a little bit over
300 million dollars
in expenditures for ies independent
expenditures
to almost three billion dollars so as
justice
and this is the same time that our
inequality has expanded to historic
levels
and there's plenty of good research
that's evolving that
um that's not a that's not an accident
the campaign contributions parallel the
inequality in this country
so to stephen's comment particularly in
the context of what we've been through
in the last few last few months
about stolen elections
we have to ha i just think it's in
everyone's interest and i'm sorry i'm
fair electric
but having listened to this i i would
agree with you mr davis i
i really wish we could have an
honest discussion give and take but i
for my perception i don't
i think the give and take is um is not
proportionate and i'd love to have a
conversation with you how we
uh have a more dispassionate
um and proportionate give and take
so that i just um
conclude with uh where we go from here
and hope that at least we can pass this
out
and i would take you up both ranking
members own discussion offline
about how we have a give and take that
restores the integrity of our elections
that justice stevens eloquently opined
in his minority opinion
citizens united without you back
thank you miss ross
thank you madam chair and um i just
want to say that this bill the for the
people act
is basically about making elections
fairer and ensuring that any everyone
can
easily and conveniently cast their
ballot
and we've had a lot of experience with
several of these provisions
in north carolina over the last
20 years but i want to talk a little bit
about what happened in this last
election during the pandemic and
what many of these reforms did to make
voting safer and fairer so in 2020
north carolina had the longest voting
period
in the entire country the state
began mailing in ballots mailing ballots
to voters
60 days before the election
now the history of our mail-in ballots
came from the fact that we're a military
state
and we wanted to give members of the
military
long enough time to participate but we
now do that
for all voters but after
the mail-in voting period started we had
19 days of early voting
and we had same-day voter registration
allowed at every early voting location
uh when i was in the state legislature
that was my bill i got that through
there was a lot of brouhaha about it
and it ended up being something that the
elections officials liked
because they could clear up people's
addresses
they if somebody went to the wrong place
to vote they could get that fixed
they could do all these different things
and have those ballots
cast before election day so that on
election day
it was easier to administer the votes so
that was very popular among election
officials
but north carolina made other reforms
to make it easier and safer to vote
during the pandemic
including in creating an online absentee
ballot request system
because of all of these options in north
carolina
we saw a record turnout in 2020
with 75 percent of voters casting
ballots
the vast majority before election day
which made election day during a
pandemic
much more much safer to administer
now voting uh reform as we've seen today
is a
deeply partisan topic and there's a
narrative that when it's easier to vote
then more people and more people vote
that the democrats win
well i'm here to tell you that's not
always true and it certainly wasn't true
in north carolina
in 2020 in north carolina we saw
in 2008 that
barack obama used many of these voting
options in order to win in north
carolina
but in 2020 donald trump
solidly won north carolina
in 2020 our
chief justice of the supreme court a
democrat
lost her seat to one of her colleagues
on the court
by 400 votes
what we have seen in north carolina is
that whoever uses these tools
and motivates the voters will win
the election and in 2020
there were not complaints about
the administration of the election we
had record turnout
and in the main the republicans did
better
using these tools any
party or candidate can use the measures
in this bill in the for the people act
to turn out voters
again we saw barack obama do it
masterfully in north carolina and we saw
donald trump do it masterfully in north
carolina
making it easier to vote is about the
people
it's about the public it's not about us
as elected officials
and we should all be able to support
measures
that make it easy convenient and in 2020
clearly safer to vote and that's
why i support this bill and with that
madam chair
i yield back
thank you miss ross does any other
member of the committee wish to ask a
question
okay seeing none i would like to thank
our witnesses
for their testimony and their patience
you are now
excused i like to inform the committee
that we will
hear from any members wishing to testify
on amendments
to hr1 at the end of today's hearing
now i'd like to welcome art witnesses to
provide testimony on h.r
1280 the george floyd justice and
policing
act representative jackson lee
representative biggs
we're delighted that you are here
waiting for them to come on
okay and just make sure it's
challenging
am i on i'm not wrong
without objection any written materials
you submit to rules documents at
mail.house.gov
before the conclusion of this meeting
will be entered
into the record
i now recognize the gentlewoman from
texas representative jefferson lee
thank you madam chair and thank you to
all the rules committee members to the
ranking member mr cole
for your extensive courtesy that you
give to members to allow them to come
before you
to explain very important legislation
this is a significant moment in history
and i'm delighted to be here to present
the george floyd justice and policing
act
that was
founded grounded in the tragedy of
police
violence against our citizens
and as well the enormous tragedy and
death of george floyd
yet i think it is extremely important to
emphasize that
this legislation accepts uh the good
service of our law enforcement
throughout the nation
uh their commitment to protect and serve
and that this is to attempt to actually
enhance and improve
policing across america which now counts
eighteen
thousand different police departments
the tragic death of george floyd has
awakened this nation
and the world to the gross injustice
that too
many african-americans face on a daily
basis
in addition it's important to
acknowledge and thank
uh the chairman of the judiciary
committee my friend and colleague karen
bass
in her collaborative work along with the
congressional black caucus
our new chair joyce beatty the members
of the
uh judiciary committee who worked
extensively
in a very long markup in 2020
and i'm delighted to be here with my
ranking member mr biggs
it is not a new story but the sad truth
is that when people
told their stories of police abuse of
murder at the hands of bad police
officers
they simply weren't believed it has
taken technology and active citizen
involvement to document and expose this
ugly reality in our country
despite protests sparked by the killing
of george floyd and others
police killed 1 127
people in 2020 more than 20
19 but consistent with the rates in
previous years
that number includes 645 killings
since floyd's death which also includes
the tragic death
of angelo quinto which is so shockingly
reminiscent of floyd's own death at the
hands of antioch california police
officers
recently
that is where we are police have
subjected countless more
most frequently black latinx and
indigenous people
people living in poverty and people with
disabilities
to other abuses through much more common
daily interactions
that are coercive and often violent even
if they do not result in death
these abuses have contributed to high
rates of arrest and mass incarceration
with devastating long-term consequences
for these and
other communities but even when
incidents of excessive force
or even death at the hands of law
enforcement have been on display
for the world to see time and again
congress has failed to deliver this sort
of meaningful
change that is necessary to meet the
moment and to promote
good policing across america last summer
in response to the call for action
from righteous protesters across our
nation the house sent
an historic bipartisan message that the
time has come
for bold reform on policing practices
in america this week we have the
opportunity to pick up where we left off
and once again send to the other chamber
legislation worthy of signature by our
new president
it is very important to take note of the
pain
that some of these incidences in fact
all of these incidences
violent incidences have generated and it
has generated
from east to west uh and north to south
and it has really impacted people of
many different backgrounds
but let me for a moment say to you that
i know the floyd family
many of them grew up including george
floyd in my congressional district
we knew of their mother who nurtured
other children
who were not able uh to find loving
homes
they lived in public housing but they're
raised with
loving and nurturing commitment
by their family big floyd
was an umbrella of love to the younger
kids on the block
this family never expected to be thrown
into the international spotlight
and what have they done with it they
have been caring and nurturing
themselves
they have stood alongside of police
officers they've marched with them
and they have mourned with those who
have been injured or lost their lives
what an amazing family and they've
established a foundation
where they want to engage the american
public on how to work with policing
how to help train police to be able to
work better with our community
that's the floyd family while there is
no single policy prescription
that will erase the decades of systemic
racism and excessive policing
this bill will finally hold police
officers misconduct accountable for
their work
or their deeds rather and separate them
from the majority of those
endowed with the ethic of just and
equitable public safety
remember to protect and serve
that is why we were proud to introduce
the george floyd justice and policing
act which reimagines policing
for the 21st century creates the highest
standards for the profession
and holds those officers accountable who
failed to uphold
the ethic of protecting and serving
their communities
we've worked very hard on this it's been
a collaborative work
yes with republicans and democrats
working together
this bold transformative legislation
effectively bans
chokeholds prohibits racial and
religious profiling
ends no knock warrants in drug cases
stops the militarization of law
enforcement
and requires the use of body cameras
isn't that interesting
in 2021 that is still not widely
utilized
it also collects data on the use of
force and creates a national registry
of police misconduct to ensure that
officers who are unfit to serve
are not able to move from department uh
to department
it is crucial that we recognize
that we can be a nation of laws
police officers working with communities
relationships reimagining that is what
the george floyd justice and policing
act represents
now i know that the change is difficult
but i'm certain that police officers
who risk their lives every day are
concerned about their profession
i speak to them every day and they don't
want to work in an environment where
they are chastised for intervening
when they see a fellow officer abuse a
citizen or use deadly force when it is
not necessary
and i'm certain that police officers
want to make sure they're trained in the
best practices
in policing we in the congress should
want that as well
to help support officers this
legislation will create
the first ever national accreditation
standards for the operation
of police departments set national
standards for officer
conduct and establish best practices in
training
hiring de-escalation strategies and
bystander duty
these are the issues that 18 000 police
departments face in the united states
and they are looking to have a training
and protocols
that they can engage with the community
themselves safely
and as they all say they can go home to
their family
and communities can go home to theirs
but despite our best intentions there
will be some officers who
cross the line that is why the bill also
includes strong accountability measures
both as a matter of simple justice to
keep unfit
officers off the street a profession
where you have the power to kill
should be a profession that requires
highly trained officers
who are accountable to the public this
is what this bill accomplishes we all
want to be safe in our communities
we all want the police to come to our
rescue when we're in trouble
we all want to support the brave men and
women who put their lives on the line
every day for us and when we interact
with the police we all want to be
treated with respect
not suspicion nobody should be subjected
to harassment or excessive force
just because of the color of their skin
nobody
should suffer the indignities of racial
profiling
or be on the receiving end of a deadly
chokehold
all americans should want that for
themselves
their children and their neighbors but
too often today
that is not a reality lived by african
americans
last summer in the midst of a global
pandemic
the world witnessed the birth of a new
movement in our country
with thousands marching to register
their horror at hearing the cry
i can't breathe interestingly enough we
saw
law enforcement throughout the nation
march
with these mostly peaceful protesters
black lives matters and others people
march to demand not just change
but transformative change change that
ends police brutality
that ends racial profiling that ends or
raises the standards of the profession
and that holds accountable officers who
fail
to meet those standards the voices we
have heard on the streets
and in district zoom calls from our
constituents are demanding meaningful
and substantive change not a fig leaf
they will not accept reform
light and neither should this congress
that is why we must continue to support
the george floyd justice and policing
act
if this legislation had been law of the
land several years ago
eric garner and george floyd will be
alive today because
the bill bans chokeholds if the bill had
been law last year brianna taylor
would not have been shot to death in her
sleep because no knock warrant for drug
offenses would have been illegal
if a national registry had been in
effect it would have revealed
that the officer who killed 12-year-old
tamir rice
had been fired from another department
and had a propensity
for violence he never would have had the
opportunity to be rehired
by another department and tamir rice
would be alive
to explore his potential as a recent
high school
graduate if the bill had been in effect
sandra bland
and danny ray thomas and pamela turner
would have been alive today
because there would have been extensive
training provisions
that would have provided uh training and
teaching against
excessive force and teaching to provide
the
end or make illegal racial profiling
and to teach how to de-escalate
we now have a real opportunity with this
legislation
to reimagine public safety so that it is
just
and equitable for all americans that is
what our country is about
equality for all i urge at this moment
in history
this significant moment in history i
urge all of my colleagues
to once again seize this opportunity and
support the george floyd
justice and policing act just as we did
with bipartisan support
just a few months ago thank you again
for the opportunity to testify
and i would certainly be happy to answer
any questions
you may have thank you very much please
now recognize the gentleman from arizona
biggs thank you
thank you madam chair and i also thank
the american member
cole members of the committee i
appreciate you having me here today to
discuss
h.r 1280 the george floyd justice and
policing act of 2021 and i'm
grateful to be here with the judiciary
subcommittee chair
ms jackson lee every human life has
value and importance and george floyd's
life
was no exception the death of mr floyd
was a tragedy
and says spark the national movement
david doran was a retired saint louis
police captain who was killed during the
violence
that occurred after george floyd's death
in minneapolis
and captain doran's life also of value
and with great importance his death also
was a tragedy and all americans are
demanding action
when president biden is calling for
unity speaker pelosi and chairman madler
have chosen to go their own way to
ignore the voices and reject the ideas
of nearly half of the house of
representatives
rather than seeking to unify our nation
my colleagues across the aisle are
continuing to shut out republicans every
step of the way
last year president trump signed an
important executive order
that encouraged law enforcement agencies
to implement best practices
provide for department and officer
accountability and prioritize
training for responding to incidents
involving the mentally ill
addicted and homeless to be clear there
are some
issues addressed in h.r 1280 on which
republicans agree with our democrat
colleagues
but is drafted the bill has serious
flaws that would unnecessarily encumber
the men and women who serve
and protect our communities and that
will make us all less safe
and because of these flaws i oppose this
bill in its current form
for instance this legislation would
lower the men's real standard when
charging an officer with criminal
misconduct from willfulness
to knowingly or recklessly in order to
be convicted under current law an
officer must specifically intend to
deprive the person of a federal life
like made definite by decision or other
rule of law by lowering the standard to
knowingly recklessly an officer can be
convicted without having any specific
intent
to deprive a person of that federal
right
police officers are frequently required
to make split-second decisions
under incredible stress in those
situations hesitation can be deadly for
the officers
or others in the general public
likewise removing qualified immunity
could result in an ineffectual
in an ineffectual police force and leave
our communities vulnerable
to crime the supreme court has noted
that qualified immunity gives government
officials breathing room
to make reasonable mistaken judgments
about open
legal questions without that room
officers will hesitate to act
and that hesitation again could be
costly
on this issue i believe there's room to
find common ground
but my colleagues across the aisle have
approached this
legislation in a short-sighted manner
according to media reports some members
of the democrat caucus
share these concerns
for instance last year i introduced an
amendment
regarding de-escalation training
programs that would help ratchet down
situations of
heightened tensions one arizona company
that developed such a high level
training program has had great success
the program's use is expanding
throughout the country
i have actually taken a component of
that training program and i tell you it
is incredibly effective
nationwide my amendment would have been
a nationwide requirement of the
escalation training with specific
training
uh module modalities that was rejected
this bill also seeks to severely limit
the department of defense's 1033 program
which allows law enforcement agencies at
all levels of government
to receive surplus equipment from dod
police departments in my own district
have used the program to acquire
necessary equipment that includes
night vision goggles reflex sights
and infrared eliminators one rural
county just south and east of mine
that's nearly the same size
the state of connecticut and spends a
great tale at the time combating drug
trafficking
and illegal immigration was able to fire
a helicopter to aid in their response
efforts
and that equipment protects law
enforcement officers and the communities
they serve during dangerous situations
and that equipment is also used to
rescue victims in emergency situations
such as natural disasters
or quite frankly those who are coming
into the country illegally
and facing the uh incredible heat of our
summers
and would perish otherwise without the
ability of that helicopter to go and
provide rescue
we saw this also during hurricane harvey
during the judiciary committee's markup
of h.r 7120 last congress
republicans offered a dozen amendments
to address these issues and other
other flaws in the bill these amendments
would have improved police
accountability
strengthened the penalties for lynching
and ensured
they're insured act of border security
chairman nathan the democrats declined
to accept a single republican amendment
we are told that our proposed changes to
the bill would be considered before
heads to the floor
but mr chairman you know that they were
not
nearly nine months later republican
proposals still have not been seriously
considered
this bill is exactly the same as it
passed the house last june
the democratic majority has done nothing
to work with us on improving this
legislation
this congress with 60 new members in the
house and eleven members of the
judiciary committee
we haven't even had a hearing our market
on this legislation
our new committee members on both sides
of the aisle have valuable perspectives
and i'm sure they could have offered
amendments that would make this bill
better
but the democrat majority intends to
pass this bill out of the house less
than a week after it was introduced this
year
there's no committee hearing america
including
in closing mr chairman this bill does
nothing to stop the dangerous and
irresponsible calls to define this final
disband
our police the idea of defunding and
dismantling our police forces
is one of the most absurd ideas i've
heard in politics
we should be clear as a body that while
we support reforms to police
accountability and transparency
we do not support eliminating law
enforcement altogether
and i would call on all members of
congress to resume
that important message mr chairman and
members of the rules committee
yeah before you the opportunity to do
what chairman nadler's refused to do
you have the power to make this a truly
bipartisan bill
to help president biden's calls to unify
the country
come to fruition i urge you to adopt an
open rule
and allow all of our colleagues both
democrat and republicans offer their
ideas for inclusion in this important
piece of legislation
again thank you for letting me take a
few minutes of your time i appreciate it
thank you both uh for your testimony
and before i turn to our members for the
questions
i would like to highlight a bill that i
recently
introduced the white supremacy and law
enforcement
information act i hope it is clear to
everyone in this hearing
that structural racism and implicit bias
have led to the deaths of way too many
men
and women of color at the hands of
police
last congress i led a letter with 27
members
asking for the fbi to release an
internal
intelligence assessment entitled
white supremacist infiltration of law
enforcement
from 2006 that was
the last report of its kind that we know
of
soon after the committee on oversight
and reform was able to obtain
an unredacted version however
this 15-year-old report
raised more questions than answers
for this reason i introduce hr 1031
white supremacy and law enforcement
information act
which will lay the groundwork to
confront white supremacy
in law enforcement specifically
the bill would require the fbi
and the doj to release intelligence
assessments
of white supremacy infiltration and
and links to law enforcement since 2006
detail what actions they have taken to
address this issue
and provide an updated assessment
information is what i'm asking for
congresswoman jackson lee i hope that i
can count
on you to bring the bill up for a
hearing
in your subcommittee and bring it to the
house floor
madam chair if i might thank you very
much for
uh a very astute and
narrowly defined uh legislation uh we
are concerned in the judiciary committee
on the issues of white racism and the
impact on people of color just last week
as chair of that committee
we held a hearing on the rise of
domestic terrorism in america
and we will look forward to receiving
your legislation
and as well giving it the attention that
it deserves and thank you for your
leadership on this issue
thank you i will now turn to mr cole for
any questions that he may have
thank you very much madam chair uh just
a couple of points and then just a
couple of questions
i mean this um last year was one of the
more disappointing
uh episodes to me legislatively because
i thought there was a lot of common
ground where we could have
could have moved ahead uh you know i
talked a lot to
my police chief since i'm sure everybody
uh
on this panel did both our witnesses by
the way thank you for
both our witness so two members i really
think very highly of
and i found they were all for more
training
they were thought a registry would be a
good idea
uh most of them had already banned
deadly chokeholds
they thought you know didn't have any
problem thought we could reach common
ground there
uh they certainly thought body cameras
would be important and particularly my
smaller uh
police departments that don't have a lot
in the way of resources it would have
made a big difference they would be
happy to do it they just needed the
additional funds uh and so i looked at
that and i thought well i know we don't
agree on everything i think the biggest
concerns were
the liability issues were officers were
concerned and that was
i mean the individual officers were
worried about frivolous lawsuits the
chiefs were worried about the problems
of recruiting
officers if they were too subject to
harassment so i thought that was ground
that we could probably have worked
through and i think
senator scott in particular probably
came closer
uh you know in the senate uh to getting
that done i think a very generous offer
of amendments and
working and but it didn't happen and i
think it was largely because it was a
political issue
and a lot of folks didn't want to solve
it uh they
they wanted to politicize it and uh and
maybe they just believed that strongly
in their positions i respect that that's
certainly
something we all find ourselves on the
occasion from time to time but
regardless we missed the opportunity
i'm sorry this year that we did not do
as my friend from
arizona suggested a mark on i mean it
really needed
not to bring the same product out i'll
make a prediction now
it will pass the house floor but
probably by a reduced margin
compared to last year and if there's not
going to be
much give and take there won't be much
change here
and so i send it over to the senate and
hope that maybe they'll get serious
about addressing it and they actually
can find
the common ground that i think we've
missed an opportunity
to find in the house because again i
agree with mr biggs i think there's a
lot of common ground here
and a real desire to do something
legislatively so
uh having said that my first question
is to my good friend from texas the
gentlelady from texas
if the senate fails
to pass a bill um this month or
next month are you willing to
either sit down and work on a new
package a more bipartisan package
than we've got here in the house or
would you be willing to consider if the
senate does come up with a bipartisan
package
and sends it back to us something like
that
mr cole let me thank you very much for
your continuing leadership on the rules
committee i think we've seen each other
quite a bit over the
years a few young few years that we
young people have been able to to serve
um i do want to just give you a little
bit of history
very quickly and then answer your
question
and and that is that you may not be
aware that the judiciary committee and
mr biggs knows uh he is
right we do have new members but uh we
had an 11
hour hearing i was just looking at the
count of our witnesses and i think they
were
somewhere between 14 or 15. i'll find
the count here in a minute
uh but uh and we sat through all of that
republicans and democrats
and then of course we had a seven hour
um i'm sorry we had a seven hour hearing
an 11 hour markup and of course there
was a lot of give and take
a lot of republican engaged and
uh had an opportunity to be involved in
this as well
we have an incredibly important moment i
indicated to you that we had a mr
uh quinto who died by a
chokehold if you will two days before
christmas and
his family called because he was in a
stressful traumatic
condition that did not call for his life
to be lost but he too
had officers to sit on his uh body
no one tried to de-escalate no one
intervened and so
we're at a crisis moment but what i
would say to you without predicting
what the senate would do i do believe
that we would have an opportunity to
conference
we're willing to do that uh and in the
conference it might be
long that we have the opportunity for
both houses which of course as you well
know
everybody republican uh members there
the senate has its own um needs for
collegiality
uh in its present configuration and i
think we will have the opportunity to
move forward
but we think it is so urgent uh that it
is important for us to take this moment
to move it on to the senate because
we've laid the groundwork for an
extensive
uh seven hours of uh markup
uh seven hours of hearing and keep
getting an 11
hours of a markup we think we have laid
sufficient um predicate uh for moving it
forward and as you well know the rules
of the house and you were on record
saying you didn't agree with them
but it allows you to move legislation
that is of such significance
and of such a moment um before april
first if you've had
um a markup uh in the last congress and
we have had both a markup and a hearing
but we will be very happy to be part of
a conference and i don't think we put
any limits on that conference we want to
get
this bill to the president's desk well i
appreciate my friend's words and i take
considerable comfort in what she has to
say because i i don't think this vehicle
uh frankly could pass the senate uh as
is with the filibuster rules that they
have and i think it's gonna have to
change
and uh you know i didn't uh didn't enjoy
voting against it last time but i
couldn't in good conscience having
talked to
every almost every police department my
district
uh you know ignore their concerns and
yet they were willing to
um and again express support for a
number of these items that are in here
the registry the chokeholds the training
the cameras in other words
they they thought a lot of this was more
than except what was desirable and
and good so uh i'll approach it the same
way this time i do want to ask one
question to you
mr biggs i think sometimes there's a
sense
and i think this bill hopefully
unintentionally creates the illusion
that we're not interested in doing
anything if you happen to be a
republican vote against it on police
reform
i think a lot of our members are very
interested in
uh getting involved in police reform
because the
the incident as my friend from texas
said with mr floyd
it's not uncommon we've had too many
instances like that
and and it was horrific there's just no
justification for it whatsoever
uh and we had a number of others around
that time so it certainly didn't declare
an isolation uh so again i think there
is a genuine desire
to do things what are some of the things
you think
the two sides the two parties could
agree on
it would be substantial reform or some
of the ideas that republicans
advance that you think democrats could
look at and say hey that's a pretty good
idea
too so thanks
for the question and
we i took a list of some of the
administrators
you are muted sorry
i apologize mr biggs you are muted yeah
thank you thanks mr cole i appreciate
the question and i took a list of the
elements that we offered last time that
and then
some of those
the hearing was was long and the market
was long
the solution was
[Music]
for instance uh
mr armstrong amendment to require audio
recording of interviews by federal law
enforcement agencies
and that's it that
that would be something that we all were
in agreement
we felt everybody should be in agreement
with that uh
there was additional penalties regarding
uh lynching uh the anti-mission
provisions that mr gilman offered there
was considerable concern
about the qualified immunity and we felt
like we might need to work through that
we could work with that
it would be helpful if we did work
through that i think there was a series
of other
amendments that dealt with some of these
these issues
including the one i i mentioned there's
a provision in here regarding
de-escalation training
but my my amendment actually provided
some very specific modalities that have
been shown to
we should probably advance on that so
there's a whole bunch of those i mean
um just some of the language that's
actually in this field
i think it can be tightened up
considerably and
um we didn't offer amendments because we
could see that the writing is on the
wall we're not going to
make any changes if we could you know i
won't go through the list but i actually
i have a number of these
items here that i think are really you
know we could we could attach to at some
point
in a bipartisan way so i will
well thank you uh for the answer and
response
and just quickly um again i think we
missed an
opportunity here because we didn't
legislate this session again i
understand my friend from texas point
that the urgency is there and i actually
agree with that i think there is a lot
of urgency i think there was a lot of
urgency
last year i think we could have reached
the deal and we didn't
um so i again i take my friend from
texas
uh seriously this will probably pass
it will probably pass with a reduced
margin
uh i think to get anywhere in the senate
particularly this issue of qualified
immunity that my friend from arizona
mentioned is a big one
uh there's gonna have to be some give
and take so
uh hopefully we'll have a productive
conference
and then then we can go from there
the senate will be more deliberative
this year than it chose to be last year
would like to get something done
legislatively on this and i do think
there's considerable
overlap uh between the two sides on this
issue where we could get a really
significant piece of legislation through
uh that would uh improve
what the situation that my friend from
texas laid down that's just simply not
acceptable in this
country so uh yeah with that amount of
chair i will yield back my time
thank you mr cole mr perlmutter
uh thanks uh madam chair uh mr biggs
uh if we were to allow your amendment on
uh de-escalation
will you vote for this bill
not until we uh thanks for the question
mr promoter not until we've had a chance
to go and deal with some of the other
issues that i think are important
not the least of which is um
the language with regard to qualified
immunity i think that's critical
um and i think also that there's some
other areas if we not if we modified the
bill to
uh change the qualified immunity and we
added
your amendment on de-escalation would
you vote for the bill
now you're cooking with greece mr pearl
motor and we can
we can start getting closer i think that
maybe tightening up some other language
that would be appropriate
um because there's some of it is just
maybe technical in nature
others of it needs um tighter
definitions because
i
one thing uh mr biggs you and i
are our friends um but i i
have to be a school
because i i just bothers me to the end
degree
i am your democratic friend i am your
democratic
colleague we have the democratic
majority
we are the democratic party
and to the degree i keep hearing
democrat majority democrat this
i will begin to call
you and others banana republicans
because the it's just
you know disparaging to not describe
us properly and that's my scold for the
day
the other thing i wanted to say
is the riot the attack
that occurred on january 6th
um mr raskin in the impeachment trial
uh put together a 13 minutes
of uh
white supremacists trump supporters
beating spraying
and in one instance at least killing
police officers our police officers our
capitol police officers
and i am so angry about that
i don't know what to say
and i just uh
you know as there's been complaints that
this bill
defunds police which it does not
and the bill that we just passed the
american rescue plan
in fact funds police to a substantial
degree across the country
but the pictures of that trump crowd
feeding our police
has me it has given me nightmares quite
frankly
and uh that anger
makes it hard sometimes to negotiate
and compromise these kinds of things we
had a similar discussion just now
on uh hr1 and so i do want to sit down i
do hope we can reach
uh compromise through the conference as
mr cole has
suggested but i gotta tell you
those white supremacists feeding our
police
will always uh stick in my mind
and then i yield back to this mother
excuse me mr paramount
yes and i kindly respond to
uh some of the eloquence of your
statement let me just try to frame very
quickly uh responses that have now been
given by my colleagues
both mr cole and mr biggs first of all
let us
look down memory lane very briefly
donald trump never put
his executive order which is a
republican republicans say they
supported it
never put it into effect um scott's
justice act
uh does not even embrace the executive
order
the 1033 program jurisdiction is by the
judiciary committee and the armed
services committee
still allows equipment and
you can be very assured that if there is
a necessity
to protect communities through the 1033
program
those assets will be given this narrows
it and makes it relevant
to the particular circumstances that
officers would want to use military
equipment
against civilians i think that's an
important point and then i want
uh to say that we really do have
bipartisan support because
uh the uh cato institute
uh the cook foundation aclu and naacp
support our qualified immunity language
let us be very clear
that is uh language dealing civilly
that deals with the 1983 civil rights
statute which was
in the uh around reconstruction uh
and uh it was created but the qualified
immunity was created by the supreme
court
uh that that made the point that if you
couldn't find an appellate
uh case that was related uh to
uh the facts that the police officer was
involved in you could be
uh brutally uh unfortunately violently
murdered or injured
then your qualified amendment went out
excuse me immunity
uh your opportunity as a plaintiff uh
we're not
uh the courthouse door this is to give
an opportunity
for the plaintiff to be in the
courthouse and to present their case and
not to give
absolute protection to an officer that
is engaged in
uh violent or uh misconduct behavior
that winds up resulting in the death of
uh
one of our fellow americans so it is a
fair due process process that we have
implemented and we have the support of
conservative institutes
that believe that it is defensible
and it is realistic and it does not harm
the rights of police officers in these
civil cases
because this is for civil cases and
the violation of the constitutional
rights of an american citizen so
um again we had an extensive review of
this
during our 11-hour markup
and we certainly are open as we go
forward but we think this still
captures both the moment and is legally
sound
uh and is also sound as it relates to
policy
thank you mr permanent for yielding
thanks miss jackson lee and i yield back
madam chair uh may i respond to uh mr
paul murder's
promise sure
thanks thank you madam chairman and mr
foreign
i i want to just let you know
mr palmer we are friends and and i will
tell you
i also was angry about what happened on
january 6th
i continued to be angry i really believe
that
the people that came in here and
breached the capital
not only did they their con was a
criminal
but it said back in my opinion the
movement that i've been working so hard
at
for so many years i think it really
harmed us
in a way that's been very difficult to
recover from and
and i hope we can my hope my hope is
that we can recover
but when you when you say it makes it
hard to negotiate and compromise i get
that
i get that but i am telling you that i
believe that
the members of congress should be
and can be able to overcome that
their differences particularly with
because i think
i don't know anybody that doesn't feel
angry and upset about what happened on
january 6th
i think it's time that we can move
together
and see if we can overcome this i've had
people refuse to get onto my bills who
have always begun on my bills in the
past because
they won't work with republicans anymore
they've told me
this is really not the way to get things
done
uh mr promoter i think you and i both
know that and so
i'm hoping that you can all set this
aside and
not that you set it aside and forget but
then we move forward
in a more collaborative process and i
think i thank the gentleman for yielding
to me madam sharon
thank you and i hope you're right and i
yield back
thank you i will now recognize mr
russian power thank you madam chair
thank you madam chair i really
appreciate it thank you
uh mrs jackson hey i just have to say i
don't have any questions for you right
now but i'd be remiss if i didn't say it
publicly i
i i truly enjoy working with you i don't
always agree with you
as everybody knows but uh you've always
been incredibly nice to me
even when i was here before i was
elected visiting the capitol
you didn't know me from adam you were
nice to me then you've been nice to me
ever since i truly enjoy your passion i
enjoy working with you
um although we don't always agree uh
chairman biggs ranking member bins
excuse me
as you know i'm a big believer in
community policing
by the way somebody is somebody is not
unmuted i don't know
i'm sorry okay thanks um as you know i'm
a big believer in community
uh policing i was a district judge
managed your district judge
uh was a defense attorney was a
prosecutor in the navy i really think
that if we have community policing it's
good and that starts with school
resource officers and works its way up
a discussion for another time on school
resource officers but
do you think that this bill does enough
to foster
community policing and get the police
engaged
with their communities
mr biggs i'm mute
thank you well thanks for the question
mr richard feldman uh
i don't think it's emphasized in this
bill i think community policing
is
when you have police officers more
engaged and you have
policing from whether it's the school
resources community
it seems to ameliorate a lot of the
hostility that
might naturally occur between the police
and the
community so i i think that this bill
doesn't really get
at that there's nothing in
what you're saying is that we need
police to get out of their cars and to
engage in the community and what this
bill does is actually incentivizes the
police to unfortunately
stay in their cars is that affairs
yeah i think that's fair because and
i'll tell you why that's that's
the incentive is because once you start
removing
liability protection um you're going to
have people
making decisions not to engage because
there is exposure and that exposure is
not just limited anymore to their
their professional life it is it is it
is
endorsed to their family and their
personal life and when that happens
people respond to incentives and they
will stay away
in your opinion does this bill make our
communities
uh more safe or less safe
i think we're going to have some
problems it's going to be a mixed bag
but i think in many respects it's going
to make it less safe because what's
going to happen is
i see police officers are going to be
moving
away they're going to away from the
communities they're gonna be
making decisions uh for their their
personal
particular family safety which is
different than they are now
they haven't they have an inherent
desire to be
to be helpful in the community that's
what they want to do but when you expose
them to greater liability
and you put handcuffs on them in these
ways i think
they're going to be um very very
scary about getting involved and i'll
just tell you that
the other thing that's happening is
we're seeing
um very very difficult for
officers to be retained right now and so
they don't want to stay they're
concerned they're leaving places where
they feel that
um are troublesome they're evil either
leaving the profession altogether
or they're going to places that they
feel where the community is more
supportive of law enforcement so
that makes in my opinion many
communities
with the gentleman from pennsylvania
just allow me a moment please oh
absolutely mrs jackson
let me um share my kind thoughts to you
and we miss you of course on judiciary
um i think it's important to
uh there are some things that have just
uh
i think need to be reframed first of all
you know we worked on the custodial
recording i want uh mr biggs to know
that that work is still going on
um i think it's important to note that
in addition to
that work um we are also uh
continuing uh if you will uh to um
to work on the de-escalation is very
much a part of this bill
but the other point that i want to make
is again
we have organizations like the cook uh
foundation the cato institute uh that
have really
negated the point that this is chasing
officers away
again uh this is a two-way street
and no one wants to have
a empty hollow response
when they're in an emergency or they
need the assistance of those who are
dedicated to protect and serve
there's a great deal of respect as i've
seen growing up and even now
in our communities of color for police
our family members are police officers
but
we must have respect for black lives
matter and also those who have felt the
pain
these families i have read the roll call
of these mothers
uh called mothers of the movement whose
children were lost
because of bad policing what the george
floyd justice and policing act does
is it lays out a road map
ending racial profiling and religious
profiling
the banning of the chokeholds all the
people that would have lived if that had
not happened
the military equipment still exists but
not to use against civilians
unnecessarily or
excessively uh and what it does
is the civil aspect of qualified
immunity
holds police officers accountable for
bad acting
but it also under the cato explanation
deals with some of the case law on
objectively unreasonable behavior
so there are standards and both the
plaintiff and the officer
has the opportunity to be in court under
the present context of qualified
immunity
the plaintiffs don't even get into court
one case in particular that most of you
have not heard of my constituent
robbie tolen a rising baseball player
his father
a pro ball player in the mlb
and he was attract racially profiled
in a white community where his family
lived because or
we call it an integrated community but
mostly white
uh driving in a van or a suv that was uh
probably of a higher cost and a
officer tracked him and put the wrong
license plate in the
report to the station and indicated that
the young man had stolen
this vehicle uh tracked him or followed
him all the way
to his home his parents came out and
said
this is our son this is his home this is
his vehicle
this poor young man was on the ground
spread eagle
and his parents as i said were out and
the officer alleged
pushed them up against uh the garage and
the young man
lifted himself up and he was shocked in
the back nearly paralyzed he
lived he lived but there were several
things wrapped in that
excessive force racially profiling a
black man driving a vehicle of a certain
amount of money
um and they did everything uh mortgaged
everything for him to have a defense and
the federal court threw his case out
because of qualified immunity it went
back it went all the way to the supreme
court forgive me for this story
and it came back to the district court
to get a new trial and they threw it out
again on qualified immunity so
i think that we can find common ground
but you need to do more research to
understand uh that qualified immunity
deals with a civil
aspect of constitutional rights under
section 1983 and it does not
under the bill that we've written the
private officer of his or her right
to be in court and to make their case
but it does give the ability
uh for a plaintiff to finally get their
day in court
and not to be immediately ruled out
because they can't find an appellate
case
that has the exact same facts of their
case it's
really important to us and it's a
passionate uh
part of this bill that many people are
concerned about fairness
i think our officers by and large across
this nation are fair and just
individuals once we get a a protocol for
dealing with the community
we'll see um a cooperative spirit both
between community and police is what we
all want
i yield back and i thank the gentleman
for his courtesies and i've enjoyed
working with him as well i thank him for
his courtesy
thank you and likewise and with that i
would yield back my time thank you
thank you mr raskin
thank you madam chair um i want to just
salute um sheila jackson lee for her
magnificent leadership
um on this legislation which has so many
critical features um like banning the
use of choke holds and
carotid holds uh in the police
departments
the articulation of the use of deadly
force
only as a last resort to repel deadly
force
which is um a common sense
uh principle that really needs to obtain
in a
free society uh the use of body cams
and dashboard cameras so um i just i
think it
it's it's long overdue and it's a very
important piece of
legislation and i want to thank her i
wanted to go back to the conversation
that was taking place between
um mr biggs and mr perlmutter which i
thought was um
so interesting and edifying um
in terms of uh how we're going to get to
common ground
on reform of uh policing and criminal
justice
and um mr perlmutter you know
expressed uh his consternation and his
pain
about what had taken place in terms of
the
violent insurrectionary riot
uh on january the 6th and
i heard mr biggs to say that
you know he understood why
our colleague was angry uh and upset
and he said he didn't know anyone who
wasn't angry or upset about it and
he shared those feelings because it had
set back
the movement that he's been working part
of um but i i just
i want to say that the problem for a lot
of us
is that the person who was singly
most responsible for inciting those
events
donald trump has never stated that he
was angry or upset
about what took place on the contrary he
tweeted out at 601 pm
on january 6 the end of the day we love
you you're very special
to the people who committed those
violent acts against american democracy
against the republic against
the house of representatives against the
senate um
and i say that because you know
we did give donald trump the opportunity
to come and testify
uh in the senate and he refused to do so
he refused to clarify
uh how he felt which i think was not
only a betrayal of his country and his
oath of office but
a betrayal of the people that he sent
into battle
daring them to be strong and not to show
weakness but to show strength
and he couldn't even show up to say
whether or not he still agreed with the
people
that he sent into battle um so i agree
with lindsey graham who said they could
have had a bomb
we all could have died those people got
into our buildings
without going through security they got
into our buildings without
any kind of background check a lot of
them uh
were armed um and we know that five
people died that day we lost two other
officers
um afterwards but i'm
i am cheered that you know mr biggs is
striking a different tone today and i
appreciate that i i hope and then you
know maybe i'd
ask you mr biggs um i don't want to
press my luck
uh in terms of finding too much common
ground but i
i hope this is there too uh would you
agree also that it was not
antifa that waged an attack on us that
this
was the mob as uh congresswoman cheney
said that was
summoned by donald trump and assembled
by donald trump
and sent into battle by donald trump and
it was not antifa
and there's a front page article new
york times today talking about how that
lie got started but
would you agree that it was not antifa
that waged this attack on us
thank you i'm always fascinated that
how you got you want to literally
relitigate this thing again and again
and again
look we know that there were
people who supported donald trump in
that group
we know that there were rabble rousers
of some kind
i have read the new york times piece
that you're referring to
um i'm not sure i accept all of their
suppositions that they make but what i
will say is this
uh i am angry at them as
everybody who came in uh
i am angry at what they did to the
police officers
i'm angry at what they've done uh to
besmirch uh what i thought was
an excellent presidency of donald trump
i i also um
disagree with your suppositions that
he's the instigator of this
i've watched it i've watched the videos
you've shown i thought that they
having tried lots of cases i never could
have gotten away with
the selective editing that you did i
thought that
i was i was disappointed at that you
were trying to make your face you and i
you and i disagree on these some of
these things mr raskin
some of these things i think we can i'm
trying to say
at some point at some point while we
have fundamental disagreements on
january 6th
maybe you think donald trump was the
instigator i think
less so than that but i think when we
start talking about
specific pieces of legislation i'm
trying to understand why
why uh democrats say you know i'm not
going to let you
co-sponsor my colon cancer legislation
because you're a republican
and the january incident i'm trying to
figure out
why you want to relitigate this over and
over again well the reality is
if you're seeking unity and you're
seeking healing then what you do is
that's what you do you seek healing you
seek forgiveness
and let me let me just reclaim my time
for a second and see if i can yeah
the conversation a little bit because i
think we are at least listening to each
other
um as to selective editing it's
interesting that there
was no presentation of video evidence
about the violent insurrection
instigated by the president
by his lawyer so they certainly could
have uh
done their own job of presenting it uh
we we did
uh 14 or 15 hours of presentation of the
evidence and
they of course did a propaganda reel of
other people using the word
fight which had nothing to do with the
issue um
so i'm not quite sure what the argument
on the other side is and i'd be
you know i'd be delighted to see what
you think was a misrepresentation
of what took place but in in any event
uh but my question for you is um
how are we gonna move on as a congress
in a country
if you say everybody's angry or upset
but donald trump is not angry or upset
and people continue
to support him he went out and made a
speech yesterday which i
watched very carefully where he never
said he was angry or upset
about what had happened those people
tried to kill
us they they wanted to kill the vice
president of the united states of
america
donald trump's own vice president they
were they were looking for
nancy pelosi and they said that they
wanted to put a bullet in a friggin
brain
and who says they're not going to come
back again they're talking about march
4th
and you i think you can see how that
would put a little bit of damper
on bipartisan collaboration on other
things
so how are we going to deal with that
problem that donald trump
has expressed no anger or remorse about
any of the events that took place
if he had nothing to do with it as some
people were insisting why doesn't he
just denounce it
well okay so um i believe he has
denounced it
i think he has contented you don't think
he has
right so so that i find
okay is that really the reason that i
have to walk through
a magnetometer
colleagues want to bring guns to the
house we know
and we don't know who they're going to
do
we know that we in our security
briefings
they gave us very clear uh information
that there is
no threat intelli no intelligence
indicating that any member of congress
is a threat to anybody else in congress
that's what they told us twice the
question was asked twice
just last week
[Applause]
when president-elect former president
trump conceded the president like joe
biden
he condemned the violent supporters who
stormed the nation's capital
that's what he did i mean that's that's
that's from a news report he did
okay well yeah the point the point i
guess i'm trying to make is
when donald trump wants to condemn
something usually you know about
right like stop the steal which he
repeated thousands of times
which was basically and it'd be nice to
hear you say that that's a lie too
but in any way he when he wanted to stop
the steal he said stop the steal
he never said stop the riot stop the
insurrection stop the violence and
afterwards
all i heard him say was i love you well
see that you and i heard these very
different things i heard him say stop
and and so and this is i guess what i
guess
when mr pearl mudder and i were talking
about overcoming this
i didn't know that when i was coming in
on the george floyd justice and policing
act that you and i are going to have a
debate about
the the credibility of the impeachment
process
here in the house and your efforts to
peace president trump
that if that's if that's really what's
going to happen on every
bill and every go into
into uh every thought about who gets
this
to to move to a bipartisan
position so where i get to sign on to
the democrat bill that i believe in or
vice versa
we're going to go back but you know what
uh you know when mr raskin presented the
impeachment case he presented this
where are you on that i mean is that
really what we've come to
is is
because we've come to a lot worse than
that we've come to an
armed violent insurrection in our own
building
and the question is whether we're all
going to stand together against that
clearly categorically where some of us
are going to obfuscate and equivocate on
it that's the issue
and i think that is the problem in terms
of us rebuilding a consensus
going forward but i appreciate your
comments today because i think
you're saying at least that you were
angry about the violence that took place
you were upset about it that moves us a
teeny bit forward
even though we're not confronting the
elephant in the room
which is donald trump's refusal to
condemn in a full-throated way
what took place and to denounce the
proud boys
and the oath keepers and the three
percent and the people that were the
inner ring of that coup against america
all right
i want to finally because what we're
talking about here with the policing
so i can't replace this social contract
right
because the whole reason if you go back
and you read any of the social contract
theorists whether it's john locke or
thomas hobbes or jean-jacques rousseau
all of them said the reason that we
enter into
organized society is because we'll be
safer inside of it
than we would be if we stay outside of
it in a state of nature
which you know hobbs famously described
as a solitary poor nasty brutish and
short
so we enter into it and then we give up
certain rights
in order to get the security of being
part
of society but but in order for that to
work the police
have got to be protecting the people and
not be a threat to the people
right and so and that's something that
the framers of the constitution
recognized immediately they said
we will enter into organized society
said madison and we will
have government but then first you've
got to protect the people against
ourselves in terms of random violence
that takes place
but then you've got to protect the
people against the government and the
police
because now you've got people who are
carrying guns who have authority and how
do you do it
so the work that you're engaged in is
essential
for us to be able to make democracy work
in this century for everybody it is not
partisan
and it's not geographic and it's for
all citizens for us to be able to be
safe and secure right so
my question for you is in
moving forward the george floyd justice
in
uh policing act um how is it that
we can get support
outside of all of the partisan conflicts
that were created over the last four
years
these efforts to divide the country and
polarize the country
against itself but it was a very
conscious political strategy how do we
get beyond that
to say that this justice and policing
act
is something that is going to give
security to every single american
and also to our police officers who are
part of our family too
like the thousands who defended us
against that
is violent mob unleashed on us by donald
trump
on january 6th congressman raskin thank
you so very much for
yielding and i might say professor
raskin for that uh
very uh four corners understanding
of who we are as a democracy our
democracy
is a continuing set of legos or building
blocks
uh it continues to have moving pieces
and its legitimacy and its strength
comes from the idea that when things are
broken we fix it
it was certainly broken on january 6 uh
not only were lives jeopardized but we
mourn
the visible beating of officers
in our very eyes after we saw the video
uh from individuals who had no respect
for law and order
this uh legislative construct the george
floyd justice and policing act
not only stands on the shoulders of
families who have mourned
but it has a historical context because
when policing was organized in the 1800s
they were used to capture escaping
slaves it has
a racial context what we're trying to do
is to build policing for the 21st
century it could be called
the george floyd justice and policing
act for the 21st century
we're trying to protect police to
develop opportunities for enhanced
interaction with the community i didn't
mention that we have a whole
funding component on reimagining police
dollars going to communities where they
will work with
designing relationships ending racial
profiling which intimidates so many
and religious profiling it could be that
you are
wearing clothing that indicates you're a
muslim or you could be wearing
a yarmulke or you could be wearing a uh
seek
the tire um anything that shows that
uh and as well to again talk about the
escalation
training accreditation 000 police
departments
and no accreditation in the 21st century
so we try to build the social contract
where there is respect for the citizen
that you are to protect as well as
to ensure that crime is not the dominant
force against innocent civilians
if i might use the horrible or rage that
we're having
of incidences against our friends who
are asian americans
we are asking police officers and the
federal authorities to deal with this
unseemly attack on our friends
and we will demand a response that's law
and order in addition uh let me correct
anyone that suggests
that eliminating qualified immunity
would negatively impact recruitment
retention of police officers
because they would fear being sued i can
tell you young officers are still
signing up
to be police officers college graduates
first of all the fourth amendment
gives deference to police officers of
the constitution
we know that um police officers are
indemnified and
they're not personally held liable for
these cases but what this does is it
gives confidence to the community
that they have a right when they are
suffering like
the family uh in california uh that lost
their son right in their home
i think in their living room or when
george floyd's
uh family watched it on television for
eight minutes
and 46 seconds that's why we cry out
say his name say his name then that's
what we're trying to do to
have a cemented social contract
that in fact provides the constitutional
protections
and then as you well know section 242
deals with
uh making sure that there is a
greater pathway for criminal
accountability
and by the way there's a statement of
the administration that looks forward to
supporting
uh the house bill working with the
senate uh and moving that bill to the
president's desk
that will be the social contract uh that
will make it better
thank you thank you very much madam
jerry and i i yield back to you uh mr
thank you so much
thank you and before calling on the next
member
i just want to take a moment for a
personal privilege um
to say to you uh mr viggs
that i hear you and i very much
like you uh want to heal
and forgive uh in this panel
myself and chairwoman uh
jackson lee were not as fortunate
as some of you to have been
um led to safety
we were pinned down pinned down
in the hall just across from where we
are right now
for 45 minutes
i didn't know if i was going to be able
to go home to my family
after that i want to heal from that
but every time i see
those bloody pictures of those officers
being crushed
being beaten with our american flag
these are our capital police officers
they were so brave when they were sent
to work
without the proper equipment utilizing
their bodies
to save our lives
i want to take this moment to thank that
officer who fired that shot
right below to where i was pinned down
right below that floor because he saved
our lives
so i want to heal too and i want to get
past this
but i cannot do that until i see
justice and so far
that has not happened so
be patient with members like myself
that continue to have those triggers
because just like you i do believe
that blue lives matter too my son is a
police officer
and i love him dearly and i do support i
mean so you can take pictures please
however i also believe
that the black and brown officers that
wear that blue uniform
that their lives also matter so
with that i apologize to the committee
for taking up some personal time
let me now recognize this
fishbowl
thank you madam chair um and i just want
to uh
uh once again point out that this is one
of those bills that
did not have a hearing this year and
that 62 members
of this body were not involved in the
markups or had any input
and those those new members actually do
deserve the opportunity to be involved
in
and so sending these things right to the
floor i think cuts them out but
i am just wondering uh chair jackson lee
um
how involved were the uh police groups
i'm very concerned about the uh
the police organizations having input
into putting this legislation together
because i worked with them quite
extensively
in the state legislature and i know that
they you know giving
given the fact that they've got to
implement things and they're involved
and
they they are good people and they want
to make sure that
their profession is handled
professionally and to the best that they
can and so i want to make sure that they
had
significant input into this into this
legislation
thank you very much we know that the law
enforcement partnership
and national organization of black law
enforcement
are supporting the legislation the major
chiefs we had a witness from the major
chiefs
uh who indicated uh their
interest in a number of provisions we
were represented in that meeting
by um chief acevedo art acevedo
who happens to be the chief of the
police department city of houston
and he indicated his continued interest
in recommendations involving banning the
use of
the techniques that require manipulation
of the neck
affirmative requirement for peace
officers to immediately intervene and
report acts of misconduct
preservation of life standard
requirement in response to resistance
uh use of force policies mandate ongoing
crisis intervention training
mandate de-escalation training on
continued basis and mandate cultural
competence
implicit bias training and
standardization of laws and policy
governing the release of body one camera
um key many of those ideas are certainly
in this particular legislation
and we will continue to work with our
friends in law enforcement
so some have supported it and we've
engaged with a number of them
uh and uh as we make our way to the
senate you can be assured
uh we will continue to work with law
enforcement across
uh uh the spectrum but we are engaging
with them we're listening to them
um and we hope that they will give us
more ideas as we
make our way to the united states senate
and because like uh ranking member cole
uh there are a lot of um organizations
and
and uh chiefs in my district that have
expressed concern with the legislation
as it is now
and so i would i really think that if
you if we are going to have
workable changes that we need to
absolutely positively have
that kind of support from police
officers
and those guys that are doing the um
hard work
of protecting us and you know i i know
you
know congressman sauber you're familiar
with him and i know that he uh
he's a former police officer and he's
offered um
legislation using his first-hand
experience as an officer
and uh you know can you talk about how
this approach is better than what he's
introduced or maybe you haven't had the
opportunity to
compare them uh would you um
characterize his legislation uh briefly
please
oh i guess i don't have the details of
it i know it it uh
he's got it and i i i was under the
impression that he's had a discussion
with you regarding um some of his ideas
and uh had some uh discussions with you
about that
all right oh i'm sorry maybe
first of all here i let me first of all
say that um
i know that uh bass the judiciary
committee
myself the chairman
had an open mind for a very long period
of time as we
crafted this bill urgency of course was
generated by what i don't think most
americans had ever seen
uh in uh visible uh color if you will
and that was the killing of george floyd
as i indicated my opening remarks
technology
has generated a a new uh experience just
as technology showed members of congress
who were locked down who were
frightened for their life just as they
were fearful and did not see what
happened on the capitol steps until
afterwards
we're now beginning to see what's
happening with police officers but we
know
across america officers take the oath
to protect and serve and they do that i
think there's a misnomer and we'd be
happy to talk to your chief or anyone
else uh that uh the provisions of
qualified immunity which is well deep
detailed in uh the cato report uh that
indicates that there are many
protections that the officer will still
have the fourth amendment
uh they will have um and uh all that the
qualified amendment does is give
constitutional rights
uh to the plaintiff as well as the
officer allows them in the court it
doesn't block
the plaintiff that has lost a loved one
uh or been injured by a misconduct of
police officers from getting into the
court
as relates to um i don't know if you
mentioned this section 242
that's criminal um liability and of
course that has to do
with changing the standard from uh
willfulness to knowing
knowingly and reckless and so i we're
ready to talk to officers we we truly
believe
that in talking to officers uh they will
find that this
does change uh the construct
between the community this opens the
opportunity for dialogue as
uh congressman raskin said it creates
the social contract
it builds on democracy that's what we
would like to do
this is a house uh version that has been
subjected to an extensive
uh markup long hearing and we believe
this
is ready to go to the floor and ready to
go to the senate
and more work will be engaged at that
time
thank you and um and i would be remiss
since there is discussion about the
january 6th riot if i didn't remind
people regarding the week and a half
long
riots that happened in minneapolis that
not only officers were at risk
but citizens um significant
there was there was significant
businesses that were burned down to the
ground a
police precinct and so um you know as
we can i think we can all agree that
those riots are bad but we need to agree
that all
the riots are bad and that that that
scarred my home state um
in the city of minneapolis when um when
we had a week and a half and it
continues there was
you know there was additional not not to
that scale but certainly um there was
additional protests and things going on
um in in minnesota after
after the aftermath of the um of the
incident
but um i did want to um just
give uh congressman biggs ranking member
biggs the opportunity i know that there
was uh
that there was a few things that he
wanted to just kind of wrap up and so
i want to uh yield to him and give him
the opportunity to just say a few words
i'll get it i'll get it right i'll get
right soon later madam chair
i thank the gentlelady for yielding to
me and and um
i guess the chair asked if i might enter
into the record
two um important uh news articles one
dated january 7th by the associated
press
entitled trump convinced capital
insurrection acknowledged his new
administration he inaugurated
wherein he spoke out against the
violence calling it a heinous attack
that left him
outraged by the violence lawlessness and
mayhem
and secondarily um
there's been some discussion about
whether
um it's hard to retain officers and so i
want to introduce
a piece of disturbing trend
uh montgomery county ceasefire crime
coupled with police retention problems
and the police chief uh there admits
that if we cut
partially they're losing officers
because of intense public immediate
without objection
[Music]
gentlelady um did mr did my friend mr
biggs finish or is he getting ready to
speak
[Music]
asking my understanding is um
mr biggs is finished matt would you
be kind enough to yield i did not hear
the word scott
i'm so sorry um we have obviously been
engaged with senator scott
and we hope to continue to be engaged
with senator scott but senator scott's
legislation does not even embrace
the executive order um and as i'm
looking at it it doesn't even embrace
the idea
of banning chokeholds
it is relied on collecting data
uh it has the establishes of duty to
intervene
and mandates body cameras and those are
all very
important elements but it does not ban
chokeholds
it doesn't ban no knock warrants and
drug cases
uh it doesn't ban racial profiling and
it certainly doesn't
require deadly force uh to only be used
as a last resort
this is a significant moment in history
i think the george floyd justice
and policing act um again captures a
social contract
between um society and police
because we as americans uh heretofore
have subjected ourselves to law and
order
uh because it is part of the building
blocks of democracy
but when you do not have a fair um
social contract uh when uh
you as a civilian a citizen
are concerned about chokeholds uh
concerned about no knocks brianna taylor
would be alive today
if the no lock provision was in place
and as indicated uh eric garner
and george floyd would be alive today
if the chokehold um was uh
banned so um we certainly welcome
the senate's uh engagement but we could
not
uh find uh a way to embrace
legislation that was initially offered
by a very
good man and very uh i'm sure committed
and dedicated uh
senator that did not have any embrace
of what would need to be in a
reconstruct of the social
contract between people of color the
american people
and our police again uh to put us back
uh where we should be of mutual respect
i just wanted to correct i did not hear
you correctly and
thank you for yielding and allowing me
to provide you with that insight
thank you and and madam chair
maybe i um it should call on ranking
member biggs to give us an idea i think
he may be familiar with
congressman stauber's legislation
and if he could potentially give us some
idea of
how this approach provides a better
solution
to say that i haven't looked at it
recently but
i did talk with him last year when he
was working on it
and um he's a former police chief and a
rank and
final officer so um we discussed
everything from
uh from training and he he actually
supports many of the provisions that are
in he thinks they're
good but he also provides some
additional delusions that i think are
important and i would
i would hope that we'd give a chance to
give that bill a good look over
um it just comes back on conference so
i'm sorry i can't tell you more about
that
all right well thank you ranking member
um and i guess i think this may uh just
uh
show a little bit of why um having those
markups and having those hearings on
things like this
particularly this year would have been
very important so that there was the
kind of input that we need to make sure
that these kinds of
legislations that's going to change the
way we police
i have our police officers uh work that
we make sure that we have
all of the input and that we don't rush
things through
because i always the haste makes for
makes
does not make for good legislation all
of the time
and uh so i appreciate the opportunity
and i yield back madam chair
ms scanlon why thank you
um representative jackson lee
um i come from philadelphia and
our former police uh charles ramsey who
was also the police chief
in bc um was one of the co-chairs of the
presidential task force on 21st century
with 59 recommendations in 2015
um that that task force obviously was
established in the wake of
the shootings in 2014 um
michael brown in ferguson uh et cetera
is there a relationship
between the recommendations from the
2015 presidential task force
recommendations and what's in this bill
congressman scanlon thank you so very
much for that question and more
importantly thank you for your service
on the judiciary committee
absolutely right as you well know in the
past administration to our dismay
they dismantled patent and practice
consent decrees
which have been lifesavers for cities
like baltimore
i believe detroit and chicago and so yes
we used
the very hard work of that particular
task force that really had
chief ramsey also the former chief of
police of washington d.c
certainly long years of experience so
police officers were on that
uh particular uh task force and i think
it came about
uh post eric garner we don't mention
trayvon martin but he was under color of
law
uh because of the fact that uh this
individual allegedly was supposed to be
a civilian patrol in the cern same thing
with mr uh aubry
uh but the idea they took a lot of that
work the
chokehold uh information uh the idea of
training was very important the
accreditation was very important we took
that
on the law enforcement trusted integrity
act which was uh uh
embedded in this bill and to be able to
hold police accountable
but again to use that term uh to redo
the relationship between police and
community
i think when you have mutual respect you
have harmony
you have the ability to work together uh
and you have ability to get things done
so yes that was a marker if you will
that we started from and that document
was very important to us
yeah and i think chief ramsey in
discussing
um the work that they've done which as
you noted included
police forces across the country he
referred to the need for
good constitutional policing you know so
police officers that are being held up
to the standards we have to hold them to
but also are able to protect their
communities um
you know we've heard a little bit of
talk about whether we need more hearings
here
um i personally feel like there's a lot
of urgency to get this across the
plate and as soon as possible um the
killing of george floyd took place on
on may 25th um the bills in this package
in large part
we were able to move through the house
about a month later
but that doesn't mean that we haven't
lost so many members of our community
since then and i want to
mention one in particular walter wallace
jr
was a young man in his 20s in
philadelphia on october 26 when he was
having a mental breakdown
his family called for help from 9-1-1
and when they called 9-1-1 they were
sent police officers and those police
officers
ended up at his house and within minutes
of arriving there
walter wallace had been shot dead so he
was having a mental breakdown his mother
was with him on the street crying to the
police
officers don't shoot him you know having
a problem
and the police officers apparently well
there was no de-escalation
they did not have non-lethal weapons
such as tasers
um how how is the george floyd act going
to
help with respect to someone like walter
wallace who needs
mental health assistance rather than an
armed confrontation
it specifically uh addresses
a new approach to policing um
absolute training of de-escalation but
it requires certification as i
indicated eighteen thousand police
departments
some as small as two but no training
whatsoever
uh there has to be a recognition of a
different treatment for those who are
having a mental crisis
your constituent and as well you knew
there was an incident in rochester
uh new york which ultimately wound up
with an individual who was unclosed in
the cold
obviously having a mental crisis and
also maybe
dealing with substance and that person
did not
wind up living because a paper bag was
put over their head
there are many different uh ways that
this bill
pierces into the training so that you
knew the duty to intervene
what happened to the other officer
whoever was acting with all the actors
uh all officers doing the same thing was
there not one officer who felt
uh enough protection by the law to say
i should or the obligation of the law to
intervene i think this
uh besides also having pattern in
practice
that if there is sufficient number of
these actions at a police department
then the uh doj would go into
um determining that and then getting a
consent decree
to get them to clean up their treatment
of their citizens
what we want to do is to give answers to
police officers
and relief to those that they protect
and serve
i think that's what we want to do to
create more dialogue
safety for all and the idea
that police officers will be able to be
in communities as many are
across the nation and feel that there is
a partnership
in protecting the community and as well
a respect for them to go home to their
families so this
bill tracks the task force and really
works to
respond to some of those concerns and
and i appreciate that it's been
extremely frustrating to
to hear this whole discussion framed as
black lives matter versus blue lives
matter because of course that is not
what we're talking about here um
what you mentioned with police um
forces wanting to have um
the training materials the equipment you
know just the knowledge base to be able
to address situations in their
communities
in a respectful manner is something that
we've heard i have
over 50 police forces in my district
and we hear particularly from the
smaller ones that they need help to be
able to live up to standards
um so so we really appreciate your work
to move this bill forward and with that
i would yield back
madam uh congresswoman if i might uh
indicate uh that there are grant
programs that we've established to help
small communities and small police
departments we welcome them we know
small communities
as small police departments but we're
giving them
uh grant programs through the attorney
general to conduct
independent investigations but as well
to provide them
dollars to certify their officers give
them training
which will make their departments much
better
thank you i appreciate that and i yield
back
mr burgess
i'll hold on questions for now i have
some uh amendments later on but
uh i'll pass for this at this time thank
you mr morelli
thank you uh madam chair uh let me first
express my gratitude to miss jackson lee
um for her extraordinary leadership and
i
she's made such a compelling series of
arguments today and i i think we
all uh have an enormous uh debt of
gratitude to her
i wanted to not only express my support
for the rule and the underlying
uh legislation but you know we all
i think look at this through our lived
and learned experience and
what's happened in our community uh and
in the last year two incidents in
rochester
new york that i have the privilege of
representing uh jump out to me about the
importance of really having and i don't
like this term it seems cliched but
literally a profound uh shift in our
paradigm around
policing and i think this legislation is
aimed directly at that
about a year ago a uh a gentleman by the
name of daniel prude
who lived in chicago and had a brother
joe who lives in
rochester mr prude was having a mental
health
crisis and in the early
morning hours of late march of last year
his brother called a mental health
arrest in called 9-1-1 the police
showed up and it was as is want to be
often the case in rochester was snowing
in late march
on a cold snowy night mr pruitt who was
naked
was put face down in the middle of the
street
handcuffed and police officers stood
around
one ultimately even though mr prude made
no attempts at resisting
um officer knelt on his back
they put a spit hood over his head
and ultimately mr prude was put into an
ambulance
but died asphyxiation in police custody
in the hospital several days later
a month ago a um
nine-year-old girl in rochester new york
who police had been summoned because of
a 9-1-1 call
found her in the middle of a family
disturbance
and tried to restrain her
her mother had indicated some concern
over the
young girl's potential to harm herself
or others but
in the course of trying to
deal with her rochester police officers
handcuffed her
and then because she desperately wanted
to see her father who she kept calling
for
um and at one point a police officer
said to her you're acting like a child
nine-year-old replied i am a child he
ultimately pepper sprayed her
in the eyes to get her inside a police
vehicle
these as you can imagine in a community
in upstate new york
have led to massive protests and
demonstrations about
the appropriate uh use of police actions
against
these two individuals uh mr pruitt
should be alive today
shouldn't have died and the young girl
should have had aid and comfort
in a moment of incredible distress to
her
both are african-americans both
retreated
with and and i am no expert on police
protocol police procedures not what
i have a history of knowing much about
but i do know
that in both cases a degree of humanity
and care and concern
and bringing together the right services
to intervene
would have led to far less dramatic
outcomes i think mr
prude would be alive today if we had a
far better system of bringing mental
health services
to mental health arrests i point this
out only because
each one of our communities has been
beset
by these challenges and i appreciate
the bold decisive move to advance this
legislation and
much other legislation like it but this
is critically important at a time and i
and i really appreciate um i think
mr jackson lee said this but others have
said it as well you know those who want
to see this as a binary question
of you're either for black lives matter
or blue lives matter
it misses the point entirely uh this
cannot be a binary question
we can't make a choice here because it's
a false choice
what we need to do is reform policing
and i
appreciate my colleagues on both sides
who've said
many people in the law enforcement
community see this as clearly as we do
that reform is uh not only desirable
it's essential if we're ever going to
get after the
deep divisive uh long history of
structural racism in this country so
i just point out that my community
continues to suffer
continues to be in pain i think this
action today and hopefully
in the next several days when he passes
in the house and i look forward to the
senate acting and
just getting to the president's desk but
this is an important critical
step in our uh our efforts to heal this
country
and to bring justice for everyone with
that uh yeah ms morelli if i might
uh miss morelli isani
thank you madam chair i just want to
commend congresswoman jackson lee and
everyone who's put so much hard work
into this effort
i'm proud to be a co-sponsor and look
forward to
it passing the house in the committee
thank you miss ross
thank you madam chair and thank you so
much to congresswoman jackson lee for
bringing this important legislation
forward we've
talked a little bit about how some of
the freshmen
didn't get a chance to deal with this in
judiciary or
during the markup i would just point out
that
this legislation has been a long time
coming
and i feel very comfortable
moving forward on it i i believe that
the public
is ready for it has been ready for it
for a long time
and um before i just give my brief
remarks
that i had been thinking about before i
just want to say one thing about
qualified immunity
i am an attorney and i want you
to know that you know if we say that we
accept
the law of qualified immunity of the
past
that means we're frozen in time it means
that no one can ever be held accountable
for anything where our mores have
changed
where our society has changed if we say
that somebody
has to have had that exact same thing
already ruled on by our courts
from a time past then it means we cannot
um have the law evolve i am proud to say
that the fourth circuit recently
had some evolution in the qualified
immunity space this year
but um we need to understand
that what was okay in the past
is simply not okay now and it probably
wasn't okay
back then it largely wasn't but we can't
accept that um the law does not adapt to
the times
and i just want to bring that up for
qualified immunity
i do we all know that last summer our
nation reached a tipping point
with grief for george floyd brianna
taylor and
countless other black and brown
americans
killed by police and um and we just
the nation exploded into action
and i would say in the main that was
positive
action tens of millions of americans of
all races participated in racial justice
protests
in 2020 estimated to be the largest
movement in american history
and i can tell you i live five blocks
from downtown raleigh and i saw people
who i have never seen participate in a
protest
largely caucasians
out on the street showing their
solidarity
and their support during this very very
difficult moment and so what happened
last year this house met the people's
call with the george floyd justice and
policing act
and i'm glad we're taking this
transformative legislation
up today at a time when it can become
law
my state of north carolina is no
stranger
to bias in policing and systemic racism
i mean it what it is
part of the south but i want you to know
that
it has moved forward and um in my time i
worked to pass the south's first
anti-racial profiling bill
with support from the african-american
head of our highway patrol and some
bipartisan support
in north carolina and i'm i firmly
believe that we need to take
this kind of action to the national
stage
this bill builds on efforts to prohibit
federal state and local law enforcement
from discriminatory profiling
and that is what is at the root
of what happens later it also mandates
training on profiling and requires law
enforcement to collect data on police
encounters
it creates it also creates many other
critical measures that we've talked
about today
but getting to this route of profiling
is crucial we have to protect
our people protect and serve our people
i'm proud to support the bill
and i yield back i know i'm a milkshake
thank you
uh chair may i just respond to very
briefly to
unless you're gonna give us because we
are way beyond our time
thank you so very much um congressman
ross thank you so very much for
um that summarization and to mr morelli
let me appoint you to section 306
in the legislation thank you for your
words dealing with crisis intervention
because police officers should not
and do not want to be social workers and
so we've looked at that
and we understand uh that that uh is
something that needs to be corrected
for the relationship to be strengthened
but we also know
that though that behavior uh of those
officers
uh evidence uh police misconduct or at
least
uh bad judgment uh and a gentleman lost
his life and a
young girl is probably traumatized for
the rest of her life
as it relates to the issue of qualified
immunity congressman ross thank you for
both
your interpretation or your analysis as
well as
uh your work on in racial profiling uh
which is in this legislation
against racial and religious profiling
where we've seen people lose their life
because they have been profiled
and that is a young autistic young man
in colorado
who was stopped on the streets uh and
misidentified
uh and he uh was stopped primarily
because
he was an african-american so the names
that we called out today
eric garner michael brown uh and laquan
mcdonald tamir rice walter scott freddie
gray
um sandra bland robbie tolin pamela
turner danny ray thomas
uh avedo diablo sean bell only a few
numbers
mr blake uh mr brooks mr aubry
just a few names that we were able to
see because of technology
are just a sample of why we need this
renewed responsibility and relationship
between police and community
so i would ask my colleagues to realize
that the george floyd justice and
policing act
has life it has families who are
mourning
it has the george floyd family who every
day
has to be reminded of eight minutes and
46 seconds
and what i will just say is that it is
constitutionally grounded
and it gives us an opportunity for a new
start
for police and community in no way
diminishes the respect
for law enforcement or diminishes the
respect
for the rights of all people and i would
ask my colleagues to have this
legislation uh go to the floor and for
us to be able to debate it i think
karen bass chairman nadler the judiciary
committee
uh congressional black caucus and all of
my colleagues
almost 200 uh that are sponsoring this
this time and we look forward to
more of those on the floor of the house
madam chair i yield back
thank you does any other member of the
committee wish to ask a question
seeing none i would like to thank our
witnesses for their testimony you are
now confused
i want to uh welcome our next panel
um honorable pete
sauber and honorable debbie
lesko from arizona
thank you thank you thank you for
providing ms lesko
thank you for providing testimony today
any written materials that you submit to
rules documents at mail.house.gov
before the conclusion of this hearing
will
without objection be entered into the
record
i now recognize uh
the gentleman um strawberry for me
mexico minnesota yeah thank you very
much uh
um it's great to be with you all and i
i've listened to the dialogue wonderful
dialogue
uh
very low volume sir can you speak up or
get closer to your mic
okay i just appreciate the opportunity
to be with you all today and for the
opportunity to speak on my amendment to
h.r
1280 the george floyd justice act of
policing of 21
uh 2021 my amendment which is a
substitute amendment
would replace the language h.r 1280 with
my bill
the justice act legislation that
received bipartisan bicameral support
last congress
you know before i had the privilege of
serving my constituents in the house of
representatives
i served my hometown of duluth minnesota
as a law enforcement officer for over
two decades
you know when i watched the george floyd
video of george floyd dying at the hands
of indianapolis police officers who
served under the same
oath i was at a loss for words
what i saw on that video goes against
everything i stood for
as a law enforcement officer with over
two decades of experience however
i can tell you that the overwhelming
majority of police officers are good
and moral people no one
dislikes a bad police officer more than
a good police officer
they dedicate their lives to keeping
their communities safe
sometimes placing themselves in harm's
way in order to do so
i might not be here today
without the actions of the duluth police
department
you see on december 15th of 1995
a career criminal tried to take my life
i was off duty at the time
and he shot through my truck window and
the bullet struck me in the head
by the grace of god i'm here today
and as i waited for that criminal to
finish me off because i had no idea
who was coming after me i heard the
police sirens
and i couldn't wait for those sirens to
get closer because i knew
help was on on the way and as those
sirens got closer and louder
i said i prayed please whoever's trying
to kill me
don't do it and when that plea the first
squad car came into that gas station
and raced and parked next to my vehicle
i knew at that time
that whoever was trying to take my life
was not going to do it because i had a
police officer with me
so every time for 23 years
that i turned on those red lights and
sirens it meant
whomever is in danger you hear the
sirens were coming to you
we're going to help you whatever it is
you call for
hang on we're going to be there
with all this in mind i know that
members of this body
do not want to inadvertently make our
communities
and law enforcement and law enforcement
officers less safe
but the justice and policing act
will make that a reality and that is why
i'm asking you
to accept my amendment the justice act
that senator scott and i wrote together
he wrote it coming from his perspective
as a black man growing up in south
carolina i
wrote it as from my perspective as a
white male police officer
in the state of minnesota the justice
act
increases body cameras and implements
duty to intervene
and de-escalation training it improves
hiring and recruitment practices